chers collègues mesdames monsieur
nous poursuivons ce matin nos travaux
sur la thématique santé des femmes au
travail avec deux de nos rapporteurs en
présentiel Annick jacquemais et
Marie-Pierre Richer avons-nous d'autres
collègues qui sont connectés non c'est
pas autorisé la visio geste bien ce que
je pensais donc vous savez les en fait
on peut vous avez les deux collègues qui
ont réussi à braver les greffes quand
même il faut le souligner et donc qui
rentreront peut-être en mode doux dans
leur département puisque voilà ils vont
pédaler voilà donc merci à Marie Pierre
Riché et Annick Jacquemin d'avoir
poursuivi leur séjour à Paris et d'avoir
peut-être risqué de ne pas rentrer dans
de bonnes conditions dans leur
département respectifs nous nous
penchons aujourd'hui sur la question des
risques professionnels physiques et
psychosociaux et maladies
professionnelles auxquelles les femmes
sont exposées
une étude de l'ANAC agence nationale
pour l'amélioration des conditions de
travail publiées en juillet 2022
pointent une sous-estimation de ces
risques tout particulièrement dans les
secteurs à prédominance féminine secteur
du Caire du nettoyage de l'alimentation
conséquemment les politiques de
prévention sont moins développées dans
ces secteurs or les accidents du travail
ont augmenté de 42% chez les femmes
entre 2001 et 2019 et le risque
d'accident du travail est aujourd'hui le
même pour le secteur des services à la
personne que dans le BTP les femmes sont
deux fois plus exposées au risque de
troubles musculo-squelettiques TMS que
les hommes les cancers d'origine
professionnelle sont nombreux et une
étude de l'Inserm publiée en 2018 a
montré une augmentation de 26% du cancer
du sein en cas de travail de nuit une
étude de la DARES publiée en janvier
2023 prolonge ce diagnostic en mettant
en avant une exposition différenciée des
femmes et des hommes aux risques
professionnels qui s'expliquent bien sûr
par des métiers souvent différents mais
s'observent aussi au sein même des
professions les hommes sont ainsi
davantage exposés aux sollicitations
physiques que les femmes qui le sont
davantage aux sollicitations
psychosociales cette exposition au
risque psychosociaux n'est pas sans lien
avec les problématiques de charge
mentales et de santé mentale qui
préoccupe particulièrement nos
rapporteurs
il est en effet inquiétant que la
dépression touche deux fois plus les
femmes que les hommes pour approfondir
ces différents sujets nous accueillons
ce matin et je vous remercie également
mesdames d'abord d'avoir bravé les
difficultés de circulation d'être en
présentiel avec nous et en également
visio madame donc Karine Briard
économiste statisticienne à la DARES
spécialiste des questions d'égalité
femme homme auteur de l'étude intitulée
conditions de travail et mixité quelle
différence entre professions et entre
femmes et hommes donc vous êtes connecté
en visio avec nous bonjour madame et
bienvenue Florence chaper on dit le thé
ou pas
non on dit pas donc Madame chaper
responsable du projet jean-réalité santé
et conditions de travail à la ANAC
auteur de l'étude que j'évoquais sur la
sinistralité au travail selon le sexe
mais aussi d'études sur la conciliation
conciliation entre grossesse et travail
ou encore sur l'amélioration de la
prévention pour une approche par le
genre le docteur Agnès Aublet Cuvelier
adjointe au directeur des études de la
recherche de l'Institut national de
recherche et de sécurité et spécialiste
des TMS et Mélodie béor Guérin j'ai bien
prononcé c'est bien très bien
ergothérapeute ergonome qui intervient
également comme experte endommage
corporel dans le cadre de procédures
judiciaire et bien bienvenue à vous
quatre mesdames donc c'est on a une
présentation genre puisque quatre femmes
pour pas se parler de la présentation de
la santé des femmes
parler de la santé des femmes c'est
particulièrement genre et ce matin mais
je ne doute pas que les travaux seront
extrêmement précis et que on est plus
habitué à avoir des tables d'hommes en
général donc c'est bien que de temps en
temps il n'y a que des femmes qui soient
aussi au rendez-vous en tant
qu'expertent premièrement donc vos
présentations pourront circuler autour
de deux axes d'abord un état des lieux
des constats dressés par les organismes
que vous représentez et des facteurs
explicatifs de la sous-estimation des
risques professionnels auxquels les
femmes sont exposées et ensuite les
recommandations que vous pouvez formuler
afin d'améliorer la prise en compte de
ces risques ainsi que les politiques de
prévention à destination des femmes donc
je vais d'abord laisser la parole à
Karine Briard de la DARES qui intervient
par visio à vous madame on vous écoute
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente vous
m'entendez toutes et tous bien
parfaitement
alors moi je travaille plusieurs années
sur les inégalités professionnelles
entre les femmes et les hommes notamment
sur l'inégale répartition dans l'emploi
et en particulier entre professions
quelles sont les mécanismes à l'oeuvre
quelles sont les conséquences de cette
ségrégation professionnelle et donc je
me suis naturellement intéressée aux
conditions de travail alors j'ai
exploité les données de l'Enquête
nationale conditions de travail de la
DARES qui a été conduite en 2019 donc
les données très récentes pour éclairer
deux questions dont vous avez parlé
alors je me suis centrée sur la
population salariée et j'ai cherché donc
à savoir d'une part dans quelle mesure
les conditions de travail différentes
les métiers selon qu'ils sont
principalement exercés par des femmes
par des hommes et puis deuxième deuxième
angle observe-t-on des différences entre
femmes et hommes au sein des même
métiers
alors dans l'enquête je dispose
d'informations sur plus de 19000
salariés qui exercent 88 familles qui a
88 professions famille professionnelles
différentes et j'ai considéré une gamme
très étendue de conditions de travail en
appuyant sur près de 100 questions dans
l'enquête conditions de travail et en
tenant compte des interactions entre ces
conditions de travail par exemple le
fait que le port de charge Lourdes est
différent selon que la cadence est
imposée ou que le ou que le travailleur
peut s'organiser lui-même que les forces
d'amplitude horaire sont associés à des
horaires flexibles ou modulables etc
alors évidemment dans le dans le temps
imparti je ne pourrais pas développer
tous les résultats mais on pourra on
pourra revenir sur certains si vous le
souhaitez et donc je vais mettre je vais
souligner quelques points qui me
semblent important qui ressortent de
l'analyse quantitative
alors premier point donc le rôle de la
ségrégation professionnelle dans les
dans les expositions différenciées des
familles des hommes
alors moi je suis partie des professions
j'ai cherché d'abord à les catégoriser
en fonction des conditions de travail et
j'ai observé qu'il y avait trois grandes
lignes de différenciation qui émergent
la pénibilité physique à ce que les
salariés sont plus ou moins exposés à la
pénibilité et ça ça conditionne aussi
d'autres conditions de travail le manque
d'autonomie et les marges de manœuvre
dans l'organisation de son travail et
les contraintes d'organisation du temps
de travail les longues semaines de
travail les journées fractionnées etc
et si par ailleurs on croise ces
éléments de différenciation entre les
professions avec le décret de mixité en
fait on se rend compte que les 88
professions elles peuvent se dispatcher
en cinq grands groupes deux grands
groupes de métiers après dominance
masculine deux grands groupes de métiers
prédominance féminines et puis un groupe
de métiers mixtes alors le groupe de
métier a prédominance féminine il y en a
un premier qui démarque avec une forte
exposition à plusieurs risques
psychosociaux qui est composé donc c'est
un groupe qui est composé
essentiellement de métiers de service on
va y trouver aussi bien les agents
d'entretien que les enseignants les
vendeurs les aides-soignants donc ça ça
regroupe après un salarié sur quatre
on a un deuxième groupe de métiers
féminisés ou des salariés sont
relativement peu exposés à la plupart
des risques relativement à l'ensemble
des salariés donc ça ce sont surtout des
métiers qu'on peut qualifier de bureau
qui paient administratifs secrétaire
mais aussi on va trouver les assistants
maternelles dans ce groupe ça représente
ça pour cent des salariés
on a un premier groupe de métiers
masculinisés qui lui est très exposé à
la pénibilité physique au manque
d'autonomie dans pour organiser son
travail il s'agit essentiellement de
métiers d'ouvriers comme les conducteurs
de véhicules les ouvriers la main du
tension du BTP ça ça représente à peu
près un salarié sur cinq
en deuxième groupe de métier après
dominance masculine avec des salariés
qui à l'inverse on peut soumis à la
pénibilité physique il dispose d'une
certaine autonomie on va y trouver les
quatre commerciaux les ingénieurs de
l'informatique pour le citer que
quelqu'un que quelques professions ça
représente aussi un salarié sur cinq et
puis on a un groupe de métier mixtes ou
les conditions de travail peuvent être
variées mais globalement on observe que
les salariés ont pour point commun
d'être peut exposer à la pénibilité
physique relativement aux autres dispose
d'une certaine autonomie et par contre
ils peuvent être soumis à des
contraintes d'organisation du temps de
travail avec des longues semaines de
travail
adjoints en dehors de son de ses heures
habituelles etc
donc ça c'est donc c'est 21% de la
population salariée qui se trouve dans
qui exercent un de ces métiers
on y trouve un salarié sur deux qui est
cadres
on va trouver par exemple les catégories
à la fonction publique des attachés
commerciaux
donc on a cinq grands groupes de métiers
donc qui se différencient par leur
condition de travail et leur degré de
mixité
le deuxième point que donc que là on
avant l'analyse et qui était une de mes
questions c'était
en fait que on observe que les
conditions de travail elles diffèrent
aussi entre femmes et hommes au sein
même des professions
donc les travaux de sociologue et
ergonomes l'ont bien mis en évidence sur
des populations circonscrites au sein
des entreprises des ateliers on
l'observe aussi au sein des professions
et ça on peut l'expliquer par le fait
que les femmes et les hommes ils ont la
même profession ils peuvent être
affectés à des tâches différentes avoir
des modalités d'exercice différents
avoir des milieux de travail qui sont
différents par exemple on peut avoir
dans une même profession des femmes qui
vont être davantage dans des petites
entreprises et des hommes dans des
grandes entreprises et donc des milieux
de travail où les conditions de travail
sont différentes
alors là je n'ai pas cherché à
identifier précisément les causes j'ai
fait de l'observation
est-ce que ce que je constate c'est que
dans la plupart des métiers les hommes
apparaissent plus confrontés aux risques
physiques leurs homologues féminines
quand bien même femme et homme aurait la
même durée de travail
alors c'est en particulier le cas chez
les ouvriers qui sont par ailleurs les
plus exposés à la pénibilité physique
donc les hommes ouvriers sont encore
plus exposés en moyenne que les femmes
ouvrières à la pénibilité physique on
trouve par contre que certaines femmes
peuvent être plus exposées que leurs
homologues masculins dans certains
métiers féminisés de service
par exemple chez les enseignants ou les
caissiers employés libre-service on
observe qu'elles sont plus soumises que
les hommes à des postures pénibles
et puis plus généralement c'est un des
même métiers on observe que les femmes
elles sont plus exposées au risque
psychosociaux de toute nature elles ont
généralement d'autonomie ça c'est un
trait qui ressort de façon assez nette
elles sont aussi plus exposées
elles souffrent de plus d'un manque de
soutien et de reconnaissance dans leur
travail elles aiment aussi plus souvent
des conflits de valeur donc le fait de
ne pas pouvoir bien faire son travail
d'avoir une qualité empêché
alors on trouve des hommes qui sont plus
confrontés que leurs homologues
féminines à ses risques aussi mais ce
sont des hommes qui sont plutôt dans des
métiers féminisés tels que employés
administratifs donc là c'est un résultat
intéressant ce sont des hommes
minoritaires dans des
métiers plutôt de bureau et qui sont de
fait exposés aussi bien aux risques
physiques plus que leurs homologues
féminines mais aussi au risque
psychosociaux
et puis ce qui est intéressant aussi
dans les résultats c'est qu'on voit que
les femmes et les hommes sont soumis à
des contraintes d'organisation du temps
de travail qui sont de nature différente
on a les hommes qui effectuent plus
souvent des heures supplémentaires qui
sont plus souvent en dehors de leur
temps professionnels qui travaillent
plus souvent en horaires décalé qui
connaissent moins souvent leurs horaires
en avant alors que les femmes elles vont
être plus souvent à travailler le
week-end comparé à leurs homologues
masculins des mêmes professions avoir
des horaires rigides qui ne sont pas
concertés et puis elle déclarent aussi
plus souvent que les hommes avoir des
difficultés à s'absenter en cas
d'imprévus
alors au-delà des au-delà des chiffres
et des constats moi il me semble que que
les travaux alors dans leur quand on les
regarde plus finement que ce que je
viens de faire il soulève deux grandes
problématiques et sûrement qu'ils vont
être traités dans les interventions qui
suivent la première la première
problématique soulevée c'est que
on voit que une importance des facteurs
de risque psychosociaux dans certains
métiers qui interroge de fait sur la
sous-estimation de ces risques dans des
professions où souvent le travail réel
dépasse le travail prescrit donc c'est
particulièrement le cas dans les métiers
de service on a une interaction avec
avec le client l'usager le patient ou le
travailleur doit faire des arbitrages
qui sont parfois subtils entre empathie
et prise de distance ou des objectifs
quantitatifs les nombres de production
sont parfois contradictoires avec la
volonté du travailur de bien faire son
travail et de
voilà et donc ça ça c'est une
problématique il me semble très très
importante et qui qui traverse beaucoup
des résultats quantitatifs que que j'ai
pu mettre en évidence puis la deuxième
la deuxième problématique c'est qu'il me
semble intéressant voir peut-être
nécessaire d'analyser les conditions de
travail au travers du prisme des
comportements et des représentations
j'enrées parce qu'on sait bien les
stéréotypes de genre les infusent sur
les orientations professionnelles et les
métiers qui exercent les femmes et les
hommes mais c'est normes sociales elles
jouent aussi sur la façon dont les
travailleurs
occupent leur emploi les les contraintes
auxquelles il doit faire face les
difficultés qui leur sont auxquelles il
doit faire face les attentes qui leur
sont adressées et les ressources qu'ils
peuvent mobiliser qui dépendent aussi de
tout un processus de socialisation dans
le travail mais aussi en dehors
et alors on le sait très bien il y a des
difficultés qui sont genre typiquement
les agressions sexistes donc ils sont
dirigés à l'envers des femmes et qui
peuvent leur causer voilà plus de
difficultés dans certaines professions
dans certains environnements de travail
mais on voit aussi sur beaucoup d'autres
dimensions c'est le poids c'est énorme
social qui qui pourrait expliquer
certaines différences entre les femmes
et les hommes et je pense en particulier
aux contraintes d'organisation du temps
de travail parce qu'on peut par exemple
se demander dans quelle mesure l'emprise
du temps professionnel sur le temps
personnel des hommes le fait qu'il soit
plus souvent joint en dehors de leur
heures de travail habituelles qui ne
fassent plus d'heures supplémentaires
que les femmes etc à même profession il
y a même durée de temps de travail
hebdomadaire on peut se demander en quoi
cette emprise du temps professionnel sur
le temps personnel ne dépend pas n'est
pas la matérialisation d'une injonction
sociale qui est faite aux hommes de de
d'être disponible parce qu'on les voit
encore souvent comme décharger des
tâches domestiques ou des charges
familiales et voilà ce n'est qu'un
exemple parmi beaucoup d'autres qu'on
pourrait aborder mais voilà donc il me
semble que c'est une combinaison
d'approche quantitative qualitative qui
permet de saisir tout ce qui se joue
au-delà de l'activité travail des
contraintes propres à l'activité
et donc voilà je pense que le regard
croisé depuis plusieurs disciplines et
vraiment fondamentale sur ces questions
[Musique]
merci beaucoup madame pour cette
présentation très complète je vais tout
de suite passer la parole à Madame
Florence chapere donc de la haine
c'était la NAC voilà
vous m'entendez donc nous bien est-ce
que vous entendez vous madame parce que
nous très bien oui j'ai mis
la nacre qui est donc l'Agence nationale
pour l'amélioration des conditions de
travail je suis moi-même en fait très
exactement responsable de la mission
égalité intégrée qui est rattachée à la
Direction technique et scientifique
alors égalité n'est pas le bon terme
l'objectif c'est d'intégrer les
questions de femmes et d'hommes à tous
nos sujets de conditions de travail
voilà donc je vous remercie de m'avoir
invité à partager nos analyses suite aux
travaux que nous menons depuis 2008 en
fait sur le sujet alors j'ai pu prendre
connaissance des différentes auditions
et je crois comprendre que vous avez
déjà beaucoup exploré le sujet et Karine
Briard vient de faire une présentation
effectivement un petit peu synthétique
des des risques auxquels sont exposées
les femmes et les hommes du coup je vais
centrer mon propos sur une de vos
questions madame billon madame la
Présidente qui est l'analyse des
facteurs explicatifs de la
sous-estimation des risques
professionnels auxquels les femmes sont
exposées
alors je voulais d'abord tout d'abord
rappeler au préalable que c'est en 2008
la décision du conseil d'administration
de l'agence qui a décidé d'introduire la
question du genre comme élément de
méthode d'endos des marges
d'amélioration des conditions de travail
dans les entreprises et l'hypothèse que
nous avons faite c'est que par rapport
aux problèmes de conditions de travail
que rencontrer les entreprises
c'est-à-dire des problèmes de TMS de RPS
etc le fait de prendre en compte
que vient d'expliquer madame Briard à
savoir que les femmes et les hommes ne
sont pas dans les mêmes métiers pas dans
les mêmes postes majoritairement pas
exposés au même contraintes de travail
ou de conciliation des temps c'était une
donnée à prendre en compte pour affiner
nos diagnostics nous recommandations
pour bâtir des systèmes de prévention en
matière de santé au travail pour toutes
et tous
il s'agit d'une évaluation différenciée
mais pas d'une prévention différentielle
alors j'ai identifié moi huit facteurs
explicatifs de de la sous-évaluation des
risques professionnels pour les femmes
la première c'est la question des
données
et de leur analyse effectivement en 2008
quand nous avions vont démarrer il n'y
avait pas de données sexuelles santé au
travail c'est en 2012 que nous avons
publié cette première photographie
statistique depuis il y a une loi qui
est passée la loi pour l'égalité réelle
qui a exigé des indicateurs sexuels de
santé sécurité au travail aujourd'hui
dans la nouvelle BDS ça n'est plus
obligatoire l'entreprise peut choisir il
y a eu aussi la loi de 2016 de
modernisation du système de santé qui
oblige la CNAM et les services de santé
au travail de produire des données
sexuelles ça nitrait que partiellement
réalisé et pour revenir effectivement
aux données que nous avons publié il est
vrai et je crois que madame va y revenir
qu'il y a donc baisse des accidents de
travail pour les hommes augmentation
pour les femmes même si les hommes
restent plus accidentés donc une forte
asymétrie sachant que depuis 2013 il y a
réaugmentation des accidents de travail
uniquement dû à ce des femmes par contre
ce qu'il faut regarder c'est la
population qui a cru de 13% entre 2001
et 2019 donc ce qui est important c'est
de calculer ce qu'on appelle des taux de
fréquence par millions d'heures
travaillées
sur 19 millions 6 de travailleurs
salariés couverts par la CNAM TS on ne
sait pas combien il y a de femmes et
d'hommes par contre c'est des études
plus fines de l'adresse et de l'Insee
qui permet de faire ce calcul de nombre
d'heures travaillées et on constate
effectivement que les taux de fréquences
des femmes et des hommes se rapprochent
et que par exemple si on analyse par
catégorie socio-professionnelle les
ouvrières sont plus exposés que les
ouvriers au risque d'accident de travail
même si comme le disait madame Briard
les ouvriers sont plus exposés à la
pénibilité physique les dernières
données Insee de 2018 sur le périmètre
CNAM plus MSA donc les secteur agricole
font qu'il y a 42 accidents de travail
reconnus pour 36 pour les hommes par
millions d'heures salariés
alors c'est vrai que l'analyse
sectorielle elle est intéressante parce
qu'on s'aperçoit que dans les secteurs
métallurgies boischimie on abaisse des
accidents de travail pour les femmes et
pour les hommes à cause de la baisse des
effectifs mais aussi à cause de
politique de prévention
vraisemblablement plus ancienne dans le
secteur BTP transport on abaisse pour
les hommes mais augmentation pour les
femmes et nous ce que nous constatons
sur le terrain c'est que les matériels
les EPI ne les les portes de charge ne
se sont suffisamment pas adaptés à la
morphologie et à la force musculaire des
femmes dans les secteurs après dominance
féminine notamment santé sociale
nettoyage intérim commerce grande
distribution et industrie de
l'alimentation et puis bon assurance
il y a effectivement sous évaluation des
risques avec augmentation très forte de
ces accidents avec des politiques de
prévention vraisemblablement plus
récente dont des risques sous-évalués
mais c'est un rapport de l'Assurance
Maladie de 2018 qui a noté le fait qu'un
certain nombre d'affectation psychiques
puisque vous intéressez à la santé
mentale lié au travail avait été
requalifiée en accident de travail dans
trois secteurs le médico-social le
commerce et le transport
alors ça c'est mon premier facteur
explicatif le deuxième concernant les
données c'est que si on a des données et
désormais on en a de plus en plus dans
les entreprises produites par la Dares
l'adresse etc les explications données
sont le plus souvent erroné alors je
parle pas forcément de ces deux
organismes quand je vois un certain
nombre d'études d'épidémiologiques
qu'ils sont faites et c'est ce qu'a
montré Karen Messing la chercheuse
québécoise depuis longtemps ces études
résonnent encore trop souvent toute
chose inégale par ailleurs or comme
Madame Briard l'a bien dit les
situations de travail sont différenciées
donc les expositions différenciées
quand nous menons des études en
entreprise sur l'absentéisme pour
montrer pourquoi les femmes et les
hommes sont plus absentes les
explications renvoient systématiquement
et là c'est la deuxième problématique
par lequel a conclu madame Briard les
explications renvoient non pas aux
situations de travail mais à la nature
fragile des femmes ou encore à la
présence d'enfants alors même qu'en
France nous n'avons pas quasiment pas
d'études qui de travaux qui mesurent la
charge mentale si je puis dire liée à
l'articulation des temps s'il y a une
chercheuse du CNAM Livia Sheller qui a
étudié ce phénomène en Suisse pour des
conductrices de bus au Québec
aujourd'hui il y a une recension
canadienne qui démarre sur ces questions
de charge mentale liées à l'articulation
des temps
or les études montrent et nous avons
analysé les données de 2 millions et
demi sur un
de salarié couverts par une mutuelle
mais l'INSEE et l'adresse sont également
montré que les femmes sont plus absentes
sont 30 à 40 % plus absente que les
hommes c'est à dire 4 à 5 jours de plus
par an or maternité paternité et que
c'est dû essentiellement à deux choses
tout d'abord en premier le cumul des
contraintes de travail et une
publication de la DARES de 2013 l'a très
bien montré et d'autre part l'adresse a
montré que c'était lié en partie à
l'arrêt maladie avant maternité mais ça
n'est pas lié aux enfants la DARES
constate un supplément de 0,2% d'absence
quand les personnes ont un enfant de
moins de 6 ans la seule situation
liée personnelle liée à plus d'absence
et la situation de séparer divorcée veuf
donc les familles monoparentales mais
c'est vrai pour les femmes comme pour
les hommes et c'est vrai que vous
évoquiez les violences sexistes et
sexuelles c'est le cas type où les
entreprises ont une lecture individuelle
de ces sujets
c'est lié à des personnes aux
conséquences de relation personnelle aux
femmes comme pour les hommes et ça n'est
pas lié à des environnements de travail
par exemple très peu mixtes comme le BTP
ou la mode ou la petite enfance ça n'est
pas lié à des organisations de travail
avec une répartition très sexuée des
tâches les assistantes qui font le café
etc et ça n'est pas lié non plus à un
certain nombre d'autres facteurs de
conditions de travail comme par exemple
le fait d'être en relation avec le
public le fait d'avoir une tenue sexuée
comme les hôtesses d'accueil le fait
d'avoir des horaires atypiques le soir
etc voilà donc là c'est pour en terminer
avec la question des données qui sont
pour moi deux facteurs explicatifs
importants de cette sous-évaluation des
risques le troisième facteur ça va aller
un petit peu plus vite d'après c'est
l'approche de la prévention
qui est pensé aujourd'hui en France et
dans d'autres pays qui est segmenté par
risque le risque TMS le risque RPS
l'amiante le bruit et qui est finalement
déconnecté des populations au travail ce
qui conduit à une méconnaissance des
différences d'exposition selon le sexe
en effet en entreprise l'évaluation des
risques n'est pas réalisé à partir des
conditions de réalisation réelle du
travail madame Briard parler de l'écart
entre le travail réel et le travail
prescrit elle n'est pas réalisée selon
le métier le statut le sexe l'expérience
l'âge ce qui conduit à des documents
uniques d'évaluation des risques qui
consignent finalement des dangers des
risques des cotations mais qui ne disent
rien de la population exposée
ce qui a pour conséquence et c'est le
quatrième facteur explicatif notamment
dans les secteurs après dominance
masculine la conception de systèmes et
d'organisation de travail c'est à dire
conception des matériels des machines
des cadences des équipements de
protection individuels qui sont pensés
en référence à un homme moyen
voilà et ce que nous avons pu observer
par exemple dans une grande entreprise
de la logistique qui distribue le
courrier donc vous voyez laquelle c'est
que les factrices sont par exemple
beaucoup plus absentes que les facteurs
on est sur des coordes de 90 000
personnes ce n'est pas dû aux enfants
plus on a d'enfants moins on est absent
dans cette entreprise mais c'est à cause
d'une insuffisante adaptation des
organisations de travail le port de
charge amené à mène à porter des colis
au-delà des normes d'ailleurs du code du
travail et ce d'ailleurs à cause d'une
la règle de l'ancienneté qui fait que
comme les factrices sont rentrées après
les facteurs et bien elles choisissent
après leur tournée se retrouvent donc
avec des tournées avec plus de colis et
dans des quartiers plus difficiles et
sur le plan physique les cadences du
dire même des médecins du travail sont
conçus pour des hommes jeunes en bonne
santé le matériel ne prend pas en compte
c'est à dire les vélos les voitures les
étagères de tri ne prennent pas en
compte la différence entre la taille
moyenne des femmes et des hommes qui est
une différence population française
1m63 un mètre 75 voilà ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on constate dans beaucoup
d'organisations de travail masculine on
trouve l'inverse dans les pressings on
trouve des tables à repasser qui sont
pas adaptées à la taille des hommes mais
on en trouve majoritairement des femmes
qui rentrent dans des métiers masculins
et pas l'inverse malheureusement et donc
pas suffisamment de la prise en compte
des différences biologiques et puis bien
sûr social avec la répartition les VSS
etc une autre illustration d'ailleurs
c'est les femmes enceintes les femmes
enceintes dans la grande distribution
nous nous sommes aperçus qu'il n'y avait
pas assez d'aménagement de poste ou de
changement temporaire d'affectation ce
qui les renvoyé majoritairement en arrêt
maladie des trois mois je pourrais en
parler plus longuement le cinquième
facteur explicatif c'est dans les
secteurs après dominance féminines qui
vous intéressent sous évaluation des
risques physiques vous en avez déjà
beaucoup entendu parler le dernier
rapport bilan de l'Assurance Maladie
montre que sur 23 personnes pour ce que
les par rapport aux personnes concernées
par le compte personnel de prévention
seulement 23% sont des femmes
dans le domaine de la santé humaine de
l'action sociale et des services
administratifs
sur la question des risques
psychosociaux ça a déjà été très bien
documenté c'est ce qui fait que tous ces
secteurs notamment santé sociales
humaines etc sont très en retard ça
n'est que depuis 2018 que la Haute
Autorité de santé puis maintenant le
Ministère de la Santé a engagé des
politiques dites de qualité de vie au
travail dans les hôpitaux dans les EHPAD
dans la petite enfance maintenant dans
le secteur de l'enfance en détresse
auquel d'ailleurs l'anacte contribue
un sixième facteur explicatif qui est
non négligeable pour expliquer
l'invisibilité des risques c'est
l'absence de parcours des femmes qui les
exposent durablement à des phénomènes
d'usure professionnelle et donc à terme
d'inaptitude dans une imprimerie nous
avons pu constater contre le fait de
porter plus de 11 tonnes par jour les
femmes rentrées dans cette entreprise en
tant que aide de finition comme les
hommes mais les femmes restaient dans
cette entreprise au même poste jusqu'au
licenciement pour inaptitude ou la
retraite tandis que les femmes partaient
au bout de trois ans
et c'est ce phénomène d'inaptitude a été
très bien documenté aussi par Marion
Gaboriaud et sa directrice de thèse
Marie Cartier dans la ville de Paris et
ça participe du phénomène
d'invisibilisation des facteurs de
pénibilité je pourrais aussi vous parler
d'un rapport sur les femmes seniors mais
dont vous avez peut-être pris
connaissance
qui montre que à la fin de leur carrière
les femmes sont tout autant exposées aux
facteurs de pénibilité qu'au début de
leur carrière à la différence des hommes
ou les facteurs de pénibilité diminuent
je pourrais vous en dire un peu plus si
vous le souhaitez l'analyse des
expositions au risque psychosociaux
montrent aussi que les femmes sont plus
exposées en fin de carrière quand débute
carrière alors que pour les hommes ça
diminue beaucoup de travaux ont été
menés par un groupe de recherche genre
activité santé avec Isabelle Prost
Christel caste qui explore cette
question du vieillissement au travail et
qui inclut la question de la ménopause
dans le contexte de réforme des
retraites c'est
utile me semble-t-il
l'avant-dernier facteur et je suis
désolé d'être un petit peu longue mais
je termine par deux derniers facteurs si
vous me le permettez madame la
Présidente
à ça cette prise en compte de la
sous-évaluation des risques pour les
femmes la question d'enjeux de santé
publique qui invite alors qu'elles sont
encore actives à la différence des
hommes je parle de deux questions de
maladie chronique évolutives comme
l'endométriose ou la fibromyalgie dont
vous avez entendu parler avec madame
Caroline depot dans son audition mais
c'est aussi le cancer et notamment le
cancer du sein c'est vrai que ces enjeux
de ces questions de santé publique ne
s'articule pas facilement avec les
dispositifs de la santé au travail
imprégnés des paradigmes de d'avant tout
prévenir les expositions et compenser
réparer je fais juste un petit focus sur
le cancer du sein c'est le cancer le
plus fréquent dans la population en âge
de travailler une femme sur 9 ou 10 est
concernée dont la moitié en âge de
travailler
or les femmes qui ont un cancer du sein
présente une caractéristique commune
dans leur diversité si elles veulent
continuer à travailler c'est la
variabilité et l'incertitude qui pèsent
sur leur capacité à travailler à
produire or cela réclame non pas une
protection des expositions mais beaucoup
plus de la souplesse dans l'emploi du
temps dans les horaires des marges de
manœuvre du soutien managérial or comme
la redémontrait Karine Briard les
conditions du travail des femmes sont
marquées par une moindre autonomie
l'adresse la montrer à X reprises elle
manque de ressources pour faire un
travail en santé
je vous recommande à ce sujet
d'auditionner Pascal levé
directrice du nouvel institut et qui a
défriché expérimenté sur ce sujet avec
un certain nombre de grandes entreprises
avec le soutien de la DGT et aujourd'hui
du Plan Santé Travail c'est vrai
qu'actuellement on entend une
multiplication des prises de parole pour
attaquer le tabou du cancer notamment du
saint dans l'entreprise mais les femmes
en parlent ce qu'il faut faire évoluer
c'est le régime de travail c'est le
développement des marges de manœuvre
c'est la question de l'organisation
capacitante pour les femmes et comme
pour les hommes
le huitième et dernier facteur
explicatif je vous remercie pour votre
attention c'est quand même la
méconnaissance que nous avons des
impacts des nouveaux risques
environnementaux je parle des
perturbateurs endocriniens et plus
largement des nanomes matériaux si
rajoute la crise climatique ou des
nouveaux risques sociétaux des
évolutions de la société sociétale je
parle par exemple du fait que les
seniors en emploi aujourd'hui sont des
personnes et notamment les femmes qui
sont plus des aidants par rapport à la
garde des enfants et au fait de
s'occuper de leur propre parents ce qui
est un facteur de cumul supplémentaire
de leurs activités hors travail
sur le télétravail on a eu un certain
nombre d'études produites sur les
conditions de télétravail et les impacts
du télétravail sur la santé aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas assez d'études sur les
conditions de télétravail normal si je
puis dire qu'il s'est massifié je
pourrais vous en parler un petit peu
plus c'est notamment Gabriel Schutz une
chercheuse qui a montré que les
conditions de télétravail étaient genre
et que les politiques de télétravail
étaient genre et comporter un risque
pour la santé des femmes et des hommes
la DARES le documente aussi nous sommes
nous-mêmes intervenus dans une branche à
ce sujet
je prends un deuxième type de transition
l'agriculture
l'agriculture nous constatons dans le
secteur du bio
il faut deux fois plus d'emplois
puisqu'il y a moins d'un an ou d'engrais
moins de machines mais de fait il y a
plus d'activités manuelles donc plus de
désherbage à qui plus de tri des déchets
à qui revient le travail c'est toute une
question on n'est pas sûr que la
pénibilité manuelle ne revienne pas et
qu'elle ne revienne pas particulièrement
aux femmes mais c'est vrai que nous
avons vu un projet innovant dans le
cadre d'un projet transaillé suivi par
l'inrae qui a permis de voir que la
participation d'agricultrice permettait
de concilier santé au travail et
transition agroécologique dans
l'hôtellerie restauration des
chercheuses de Grenoble
et clos ont montré que une politique de
développement durable avait rajouté la
division renforcer la division sexuelle
du travail et renforcer le travail pour
les femmes plus que pour les hommes
nous-mêmes à la nacte nous finançons
deux projets dont un dans une
collectivité locale qui s'interroge sur
l'impact du réchauffement sur le travail
des agents et nous allons prendre en
compte le fait que le métabolisme des
femmes et des hommes à la chaleur n'est
pas le même et qu'il s'agit de prendre
en compte cela quand on regarde comment
adapter le travail à de fortes chaleurs
alors je conclus avec quelques
recommandations dont on pourra peut-être
échanger plus
ma première toute première
recommandation revient au premier point
il faut renforcer la production de
données sexuées en santé au travail
au niveau des entreprises
au niveau des territoires et on ne peut
que saluer que huit plans santé
régionaux santé au travail ont développé
des actions qui concernent la santé des
femmes et on produit un diagnostic à cet
effet mais c'est aussi les services de
prévention et de santé au travail
la Caisse nationale d'assurance maladie
la MSA mais qui le fait déjà un peu les
branches
les mutuelles etc c'est faire appliquer
finalement ces lois de 2014 et de 2016
ce qu'il convient aussi de faire
deuxième recommandation c'est mener plus
de recherches sur les liens genre santé
travail avec trois recommandations
prendre en compte comme vous en a parlé
Catherine Vidal la notion d'exposants
c'est-à-dire la multi-exposition des
femmes et des hommes d'ailleurs
sur des facteurs de risque qui
concernent le travail et le hors travail
la deuxième recommandation est de
réviser le principe des études
épidémiologiques qui résonne encore
beaucoup toutes choses inégales par
ailleurs pour mieux prendre en compte
les effets de genre et la troisième sous
recommandation de ce volet recherche
c'est de développer des focus sur
certains risques les risques bien sûr
dans les emplois prédominance féminine
les risques liés à l'articulation des
temps au télétravail aux organisations
de travail hybrides
les risques liés aux violences sexistes
et sexuelles les facteurs
organisationnels liés aux violences
sexistes et sexuelles et puis les
risques liés au cycle reproductif la
question de la grossesse bien sûr mais
la question de l'endométriose par
exemple la question de la ménopause etc
et tous les risques qui ont un impact
sur la fertilité des femmes comme des
hommes puisque c'est peut-être surtout
des conséquences importantes aussi en
lien qui n'est pas en lien avec le
travail
au niveau des entreprises trois
recommandations
développer des nouvelles normes pour les
matériels des outils les EPI afin de
prendre en compte les différences
physiologiques entre les femmes et les
hommes mais lors de l'audition du coq
les organisations patronales nous ont
expliqué qu'effectivement en France on
est très en retard alors qu'en Allemagne
on est avancé parce que effectivement le
code du travail a il y a 30 ans
supprimés toutes référence au sexe
sauf
la question de l'exposition au port de
charge et au plomb deuxième
recommandation pour l'entreprise faire
appliquer la loi de 2014 qui est
d'outillée ce document unique
d'évaluation des risques pour prendre en
compte l'impact différentiel exposition
en fonction du sexe et inclure les
risques des femmes dans leurs emplois
les risques liés à la grossesse les
risques de violences sexistes et
sexuelles
c'est vrai que le Plan Santé Travail
numéro 4 prévoit une action dans ce sens
pour outiller les entreprises qui
associent les services de santé au
travail
l'INRS la CNAM pour expérimenter en
région et dernière recommandations pour
les entreprises adaptées une démarche
large de prévention intégrée qui vise à
une amélioration des conditions de
travail pour toutes et tous par exemple
sur le port de charge supprimer cette
disposition du Code du travail qui est
de limiter le port de charge à 25 kg
pour les femmes et 55 pour les hommes et
appliquait la norme européenne de 15 kg
pour tout le monde et puis inclure les
risques de prévention de la désinsertion
professionnelle liée effectivement au
enjeux de santé publique avec les
maladies typiquement si je puis dire
féminine
voilà je vous remercie je m'excuse
d'avoir été un petit peu longue mais il
me semblait important de vous partager
ces éléments voilà merci à vous merci
beaucoup madame vous êtes venus pour
partager ces éléments et en vous remerci
pour la précision de cette exposé et son
organisation qui était très très
compréhensible comme la première
intervention d'ailleurs donc je vais
tout de suite passer la parole à Madame
Agnès aubelais Cuvelier donc de
l'Institut national de recherche et
santé nous vous écoutons madame merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente donc
effectivement je
m'exprime aujourd'hui au nom de
l'Institut national de recherche je ne
sais pas pourquoi il est parti ah pardon
de l'Institut national de recherche et
de sécurité pour la prévention des
accidents du travail et des maladies
professionnelles qui est donc un
organisme paritaire
qui a pour pour mission donc d'agir en
prévention par différents modes d'action
la recherche expertise
information et formation pour les
entreprises du régime général en France
alors pour illustrer les différences
entre les hommes et les femmes en
matière de risque professionnel j'ai
choisi de vous parler de la prévention
des troubles musculo-squelettiques et
des facteurs explicatifs qui
viennent étayer les la compréhension des
différences existants effectivement en
matière d'exposition de risques de prise
en charge entre les hommes et les femmes
quelques mots rapides je ne sais pas si
ça fonctionne j'ai l'impression que je
n'ai pas le
j'ai pas la main
sinon je vais le faire sans c'est pas
grave
sinon ce sera sans pouvoir pas une je
pense que je vais pouvoir
voilà donc quelques mots sur ces
atteintes donc les TMS sont-ils un sexe
c'était le titre d'un article que j'ai
produit à quelques quelques années
maintenant pour la revue santé et
travail une question qui anime les
chercheurs les préventeurs depuis un
certain nombre d'années puisque les
troubles musculus squelettiques
constituent la première maladie
professionnelle en France depuis plus de
deux décennies et de loin puisqu'elle
atteint plus de elle représente plus de
85% des maladies professionnelles
reconnues dans le régime général on voit
ici les données de la CNAM donner 2019
qui concerne donc les reconnaissances de
maladies professionnelles et leur
répartition au cours donc de l'année
2019 avec une un excédent de de
représentation des femmes dans ces
maladies reconnues
et un pic de fréquence qui apparaît
plutôt que pour que pour les hommes au
cours en fonction des âges et nous
allons essayer donc de détailler un
petit peu les causes de ces de cette
sur-représentation les troubles
musculo-squelettiques ce sont ces
pathologies que l'on décrit comme le
syndrome du canal carpien les
tendinopathies les épicondylique
l'hygromades du genou la lombalgie
autant de d'atteintes qui vont toucher
toutes les régions périarticulaires de
l'appareil locomoteur et qui sont à
l'origine de douleur d'atteindre
fonctionnels qui peuvent s'avérer
transitoires donc passé avec une
retraite d'exposition à un certain
nombre de facteurs de risques mais qui
peuvent aussi s'installer de façon
durable de venir chronique source de
handicap et même
compromettre le maintien et le retour au
travail d'un certain nombre de salariés
leur origine est multifactorielle elle
est
aux conditions de réalisation du travail
avec deux grandes familles de facteurs
de risque que sont les contraintes
biomécaniques et forts excessives
répétitivité posture inconfortable ou en
position statique soutenue mais
également les facteurs psychosociaux qui
sont également des facteurs cumulatifs à
l'origine d'autres d'autres conséquences
pour la santé mentale ces facteurs
psychosociaux que constitue par exemple
la pression temporelle le manque
d'autonomie en excédant chez les femmes
comme on l'a montré dans un certain
nombre d'études des exigences
psychologiques et émotionnelles ces
exigences émotionnelles étant également
plus prévalente chez les femmes que chez
les hommes
femmes au travail du fait de la nature
même de leurs activités qui sont souvent
très tournées vers Le Caire le soin et
les relations avec le public qui vont
donc beaucoup impacter ces questions de
contraintes émotionnelles et puis bien
sûr ces deux grandes familles sont
terminé par un environnement physique
organisationnel managériale économique
qui va jouer un rôle majeur et dans
lequel on va puiser les ingrédients et
les leviers d'action pour agir en
prévention de ces de ses affections le
rôle des facteurs extra-professionnels
existent aussi dans la survenue de ces
pathologies mais on a montré aussi qu'il
était mineur dans le contexte
professionnel de survenu des troubles
musculo-squelettiques c'est par une
approche donc participative globale
pluridisciplinaire que l'on parvient à
les prévenir et je vais d'emblée
m'engager sur les facteurs explicatifs
de ces différences donc de survenu de
troubles musculaires squelettiques alors
pourquoi les femmes sont-elles plus à
risque que les hommes là en l'occurrence
en matière de troubles
musculo-squelettiques nous l'avons vu ce
matin à travers les présentations
précédentes la répartition des hommes et
des femmes et différencier dans
différents secteurs d'activités les
postes les avec des hommes plus présents
dans des secteurs
comportant des activités physiques
Lourdes en termes de manutention de
charges par exemple dans le BTP dans
l'industrie dite lourdes dans les
secteurs du transport et de la
logistique et puis les femmes plus
présentes dans des activités de service
d'aide et des soins à la personne et
dans des activités de ce qu'on appelle
l'industrie légère où on considère que
le travail ne concerne pas le port de
charge très lourdes mais par exemple des
activités d'assemblage avec des gestes
très précis et très fins dont on a du
mal parfois à estimer la réalité en
matière qualitative et quantitative et
qui ont parfois été sous-estimé or des
gestes précis et très fins impliquent
une gestuelle qui va solliciter par
exemple les muscles fléchisseurs des
mains et des doigts et muscles extenseur
et être à l'origine de tendinopathie qui
sont tout à fait invalidante à terme ce
sont des risques ou des facteurs de
risque qui peuvent être sous considérés
sous-évalués et qui paraissent
secondaires dans l'inconscient collectif
au regard de du port de charge lourdes
par exemple pour les hommes les hommes
ont donc en général plus de contraintes
physiques liées à la manutention
manuelle de charge lourdes ils sont
exposés aux vibrations mains bras ou
vibrations corps entier par la conduite
d'engins par l'utilisation d'outils
vibrants portatifs dans le BTP notamment
ils sont plus exposés au bruit plus
exposés au travail à la chaleur au
travail de nuit alors que les femmes
effectivement sont exposées à des
facteurs de risque qui paraissent moins
évident et qui du coup sont sous estimés
par le monde du travail d'une façon
générale elle ne porte pas forcément de
charges très lourdes mais elles ont la
charge de la manutention et de l'aide à
la mobilisation de personne ce qui
constitue une charge très importante sur
le plan physiologique d'autant que
les les
contraintes sont liées aussi à des
personnes en mouvement qu'on va assister
avec une fragilité évidemment qui est
importante qu'on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas ignorer on ne laisse pas tomber une
personne alors qu'un sac de ciment s'il
tombe c'est embêtant mais c'est moins
grave et puis ces femmes sont aussi plus
en lien avec avec le public et donc à
l'origine dans ce cadre là de du
développement potentiel plus important
de facteurs de risque psychosociaux
d'autres
sources de risques existent aussi mais
on va rester là sur la question des
troubles musculo-squelettiques les la
sous-estimation des risques elle est
donc à la fois liée à une perception du
risque qui est liée aux gens
à des risques psychosociaux qui peuvent
être de nature différente
de ceux des hommes à un héritage aussi
de culture de métier la femme ou les
femmes seraient naturellement
encline à prendre soin des autres et le
dévouement et la dévotion et bien plus
noble que les petits mots dont on
pourrait souffrir en tant que femme ce
sont des éléments qui perdurent dans
certains dans certains milieux et qui
ont longtemps
entraîné une un retard de prise en
compte et une sous-estimation de ces
risques elle-même se refusant à se
plaindre dans un certain nombre de
situations parce que et bien le sens de
leur travail et l'importance de la
mission était bien plus bien supérieur à
aux mots qu'elle pouvait éprouver
l'impact de la sous-estimation et de la
représentation des risques
est aussi lié à une répartition
homme-femme dans le management qui peut
être différente et à une répartition
homme-femme aussi dans les instances
représentatives du personnel qui est
encore
insuffisante dans certains secteurs avec
une sur-représentation des dans certains
secteurs d'activités qui inconsciemment
d'ailleurs on ne cache pas
volontairement des risques mais qui
laisse moins d'espace d'expression dans
un certain nombre de situations aux
femmes sur leurs propres conditions de
travail des différences de statuts et
d'évolution professionnelle qui peuvent
s'avérer défavorables aux femmes
Florence en a parlé tout à l'heure et
puis
l'auditrice précédente aussi plus de
temps partiel des carrières plus
morcelées mais en compensation entre
guillemets la nécessité de travailler
plus longtemps d'avoir des parcours
professionnels plus longs pour avoir
accès à une retraite descente et du coup
une un cumul d'exposition qui va
s'engager avec un travail à un âge
parfois reculé et le fait d'avoir de
moindre opportunités d'évolution
professionnelle qui s'accentue avec
l'avancée en âge vont faire que
effectivement ces femmes comme le disait
Florence chaper ont moins de
possibilités d'extraction de conditions
de travail délétères ou pénibles pour
elle en matière d'exposition à des
facteurs de risque et vont être exposés
de façon prolongée par rapport à leurs
homologues masculins à certains facteurs
de risques
en matière de
cumule d'exposition à certains facteurs
de risque je m'engagerai aussi sur cette
voie de l'accumulation d'exposition à
des facteurs de risque dans la vie
privée et dans la vie professionnelle
avec des différences dans la gestion de
l'équilibre entre cette vie privée et
cette vie professionnelle qui ont été
encore plus mis en lumière
avec la crise covid et en particulier
dans le télétravail où on montrait
notamment que et bien les femmes par
exemple avaient plus de mal à travailler
chez elle sans enfant en ayant en étant
en télétravail que leurs époux qui eux
parvenaient à s'isoler pour pour fournir
le travail attendu à distance la somme
de travail rémunéré non rémunéré et plus
importante également chez les femmes
particulièrement les femmes avec enfants
et comme le disait également Florence
chaper tout à l'heure elles sont plus
sollicitées en tant qu'aidante que les
hommes que ce soit pour leurs enfants ou
pour des personnes
âgées par exemple exemple elles sont
trois fois plus sollicitées que les
hommes dans ces dans ces activités des
dentes on imagine bien que c'est
l'ensemble des tâches domestiques des
dentes de support à différentes
fonctions génèrent une exposition à des
facteurs de risque biomécaniques et
psychosociaux y compris dans la vie hors
travail qui vont venir se cumuler avec
les expositions facteurs de risque
professionnel dans ces conditions
elles ont de plus de moindre temps du
coup de récupération puisque elle
continue à travailler en dehors de leur
activité professionnelle or ces temps de
récupération sont précieux pour
réparer les micros lésions tissulaires
les qui font le lit des tendinopathiques
qui font le lit de toutes sortes de
petites de petites lésions
périarticulaires et ces temps de
récupération manquants vont entraîner
des retards de cicatrisation par exemple
[Musique]
moyen et morphologies sont évidemment
différentes or les postes de travail et
l'organisation spatiale sont souvent
pensées pour un homme de taille moyenne
dans un certain nombre de milieux
professionnels qui s'avère finalement
inadapté à la morphologie et à
l'anthropométrie au caractère
anthropométrique des femmes avec des
équipements de travail des dispositifs
d'aide technique qui vont être plus
difficiles à utiliser des équipements de
protection individuels également qui
peuvent être inadaptées on voit souvent
dans les entreprises des boîtes de gants
par exemple qui de taille M qui sont
censés convenir à la moyenne des
personnes donc les plus grands les plus
petits les femmes ont souvent des plus
petites mains que les hommes ça peut
vous paraître anecdotique mais lorsqu'on
a des gants qui sont surdimensionnés par
rapport à la taille de sa main et qu'on
doit saisir des objets faire de la
manutention manuelle on à la fois des
efforts de serrage plus important pour
maintenir le gant sur la main et pour
maintenir le colis ou les objets que
l'on est censé transporter donc c'est au
final une accroissement pardon de
facteurs de risque biomécanique qui vont
être délétères pour
les risques de troubles
musculo-squelettiques il en est de même
pour les zones d'atteintes en
approvisionnement où on va être obligé
par exemple de lever les bras au dessus
des épaules de façon beaucoup plus
fréquente parce que les
approvisionnements sont à hauteur
inadaptée et là encore générer des
facteurs de risque spécifiques pour elle
en matière de constitution organique
aussi des différences tissulaires qui
vont pouvoir toucher différemment les
femmes et les hommes sur les propriétés
élastiques ligamentaires tendineuses des
caractéristiques
osseuses également et puis les femmes
ont une des capacités fonctionnelles sur
le plan cardiovasculaire de base qui
sont inférieurs celle des hommes
parce que elles ont d'abord un taux
d'hémoglobine en moyenne plus faible
donc le transport d'oxygène ne se fait
pas de la même façon un cœur plus petit
et elles sont obligées d'augmenter leur
fréquences cardiaques pour pouvoir
préserver un débit qui permet d'oxygéner
correctement l'ensemble de l'organisme
alors ça ne veut pas dire que ce sont
des femmes faibles ça veut dire
simplement que à effort ou à exigences
égales en matière de contrainte
biomécanique ou
physiologique et bien les femmes vont
souvent de voir réaliser des efforts
supplémentaires par rapport à par
exemple leur force maximale ou leur
capacité cardiovasculaires maximales et
donc au final ces efforts vont être plus
coûteux pour l'organisme pour pour ces
femmes et puis on l'a évoqué très
rapidement la question du fonctionnement
hormonal du métabolisme de l'immunité
aussi
qui sont là encore des facteurs qui vont
différencier les hommes et les femmes et
enfin en termes de voilà de
d'éléments complémentaires on a
effectivement aussi à faire face à une
forme de déterminisme social et culturel
sur les rôles valeurs comportement
attribués aux femmes et aux hommes qui
peuvent déterminer aussi des façons de
travailler de ce comporter de réprimer
des émotions de bouger y compris et on a
notamment
identifié et rester il est resté pardon
qui a fait une étude sur ce point que
les femmes n'ont pas la même façon de
réaliser de la manutention manuelle de
charge que les hommes donc c'est à la
fois lié à des éléments physiologiques
l'anatomie n'est pas la même les centres
de gravité ne sont pas les mêmes les
chaînes posturales sont différentes
aussi mais c'est aussi lié à des codes
sociaux sur la façon dont une femme se
tient et un homme se tient dans la vie
de tous les jours
voilà alors quelques recommandations
après cette ce panorama un peu un peu
général qui vous éclaire sur la question
des TMS mais qu'on pourrait appliquer à
bien d'autres risques que dit le code du
travail le code du travail dit notamment
que l'évaluation des risques tient
compte de l'impact différencié de
l'exposition au risque en fonction du
sexe c'est écrit dans le code du travail
c'est un élément qui nous paraît
effectivement très important à prendre
en compte et qui va aboutir à prendre en
compte dans l'évaluation des risques
tous les facteurs de variabilité entre
les hommes et les femmes
facteurs de variabilité
qui sont liées non seulement au sexe
mais aussi à l'âge à la corpulence à des
facteurs génétiques des antécédents
médicaux des capacités fonctionnelles à
l'expérience des femmes et des hommes
dans leur activité professionnelle
l'évaluation des risques doit être au
plus proche de la situation de travail
et de l'exposition
réelle et elle peut et doit considérer
des caractéristiques individuelles
lorsqu'elles s'avère nécessaire sur les
différents facteurs de variabilité la
question de la seniorité des nouveaux
embauchés la question de l'expérience de
la situation de handicap sont autant de
facteurs à prendre en compte dans
l'évaluation des risques la prévention
elle doit respecter les principes
généraux évidemment de prévention qui
sont également édictées dans le code du
travail et elle doit être à notre sens
collective et adapté à toutes et à tous
y compris à ceux qui sont le plus à
risque quel que soit les
caractéristiques physiques et
physiologiques de ces personnes d'âge de
genre et de santé avec des situations
qui restent spécifiques
et qui doivent être prises en compte
notamment grâce au rôle du médecin du
travail et plus largement des services
de prévention et de santé au travail qui
ont une connaissance fine de la
situation
médicale et de santé des personnes
qu'ils ont en charge mais qui ont
également une connaissance des
situations de travail qui permettent de
proposer des pistes de prévention qui en
complément de de la prévention
collective peuvent s'adapter à ces
situations particulières il existe
néanmoins des points de vigilance à
souligner il est plus facile dans d'agir
en prévention sur certains risques alors
qu'ils sont plus visibles qui sont
plutôt masculins dans un certain nombre
de situations par l'accès à des actions
de mécanisation d'automatisation ou des
techniques à la manutention manuelle de
charge par exemple ou d'action sur les
dispositifs anti-vibratils ces actions
de prévention sont évidemment
fondamentales elles bénéficie à toutes
et à tous mais néanmoins il faut faire
attention à ne pas négliger pour autant
la nécessaire prévention de risques qui
seraient plus difficile à rendre visible
plus difficile à juguler et d'agir sur
les causes profondes alors rendre
visible des risques qu'on parlait tout à
l'heure par exemple de ces gestes précis
et très fins qui peuvent paraître an
mais répéter très nombreuses fois et de
longues années peuvent s'avérer
particulièrement délétères on peut
évoquer également les facteurs de risque
psychosociaux qui vont avoir un rôle
dans la survenue des troubles
musculaires squelettiques aussi qui
peuvent être plus difficiles également à
aborder à qualifier à quantifier et sur
lesquels il faut agir de façon tout
aussi efficace que sur d'autres facteurs
biomécaniques on peut aboutir si on y
prend garde à une forme de
discrimination aussi on voit on a vu les
différences qui existent entre les
hommes et les femmes sur des aspects
physiologiques par exemple ces aspects
ont été longtemps mis en avant en
matière d'explication sur les risques de
troubles musculo-squelettiques dont on
considérait qu'ils étaient l'apanage de
la femme ménopausée qui tricote et avec
parfois un certain mépris et donc il a
fallu effectivement travailler beaucoup
pour mettre en avant
l'ensemble de tous les facteurs
déterminants sur un plan social
professionnel etc qui expliquent de
façon beaucoup plus argumentée et avec
un risque attribuable beaucoup plus
important
les les différences de risque entre les
hommes et les femmes attention aussi à
ne pas chercher entre guillemets en
protégeant ou en préservant la santé des
femmes surexposer celle des hommes à qui
serait dévoluent le port de charge pour
prévenir ou réduire le risque c'est une
raison supplémentaire pour agir de façon
collective à l'intention de toutes et
tous et
y compris bien sûr des plus fragiles
risque de renforcement également des
stéréotypes de genre qui
comporteraient donc des actions ciblées
qui deviendraient contre-productives
vient d'en donner un exemple et le
risque d'enfermement aussi dans
certaines représentations je ne
reviendrai pas sur le cas de les normes
de manutention manuelle de charge
puisque Florence a donné ce cet exemple
alors sur les actions à mener et bien il
est évident que la recherche doit
veiller à renforcer la prise en compte
du sexe et du genre dans toutes les
études avec des analyses différenciées
hommes femmes la compréhension des
mécanismes qui viennent soutenir
l'étiologie et la survenue d'un grand
nombre de maladies professionnelles
l'apport des différentes disciplines
pour améliorer les connaissances et on
voit depuis ce matin l'apport des
épidémiologistes des
ergonomes des sociologues des
biomécaniciens des physiologistes des
psychologues sont autant de portes
d'entrée qui est important de faire
communiquer pour obtenir des pistes de
prévention qui soit intégratives d'un
d'un ensemble de conditions de travail
très important aussi la formation
initiale des futurs professionnels des
Siders managers pour les rendre
sensibles à ces questions de
déterminisme social aussi en termes de
prévention de la santé des hommes et des
femmes en milieu de travail il existe un
certain nombre d'initiatives depuis
plusieurs années sur la question déjà de
la prévention des risques professionnels
qui est très insuffisamment
enseignées et auxquels beaucoup de
futurs professionnels ne sont pas
suffisamment sensibilisés y compris des
personnes qui vont s'engager ensuite
dans des voies de ressources humaines de
management etc veillez à ce que les
concepteurs des équipements de travail
soient également sensibilisés à ces
questions concepteurs de machines
concepteur de robots concepteur de
protection individuel on l'a vu encore
récemment et on sort là du cadre DTMs
mais l'importance par exemple
de des appareils de protection
respiratoire individuelle en matière
d'ajustement au visage tout de suite
étant évidemment un facteur délétère
pour la protection de ces personnes or
souvent et bien les femmes ont des
visages plus petits et différents et se
retrouvent à avoir des masques qui sont
pas forcément adaptés à leur morphologie
et puis enfin l'information la
sensibilisation de de toutes les de
toutes les parties prenantes
que ce soit les préventeurs bien sûr les
employeurs les instances représentatives
du personnel les salariés et l'ancrage
d'un certain nombre de facteurs à
traiter à un niveau beaucoup plus macro
au niveau sociétal en faveur de la
prévention des risques des femmes et des
hommes voilà je vous remercie de votre
attention merci beaucoup madame pour
cette présentation très complète et donc
nous avons eu la chance de voir
s'afficher donc malgré le risque au
départ donc merci à vous on va passer la
parole à la dernière
intervenante qui est
ergothérapeute mélodie béour Guérin à
vous madame merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente vous m'entendez bien
alors je vais essayer de ne pas faire
trop de redit par rapport aux
présentations précédentes et je vais
faire un focus notamment par rapport aux
femmes au travail et au handicap
alors au niveau du contexte aujourd'hui
on sait que je fais des bêtises non
c'est pas moi
au niveau du contexte on sait que quel
que soit le type de travaux effectués ou
de secteurs les femmes peuvent tout
faire mais dans une certaine mesure bien
sûr et que même les travaux qui peuvent
être jugés simples voilà par par la
société ne le sont pas forcément ils ne
sont pas plus simples ils ne sont pas
forcément plus sûrs et sécurisés
aujourd'hui les femmes comme les hommes
ont besoin d'un équilibre occupationnel
donc c'est à dire d'allier différentes
activités dans leur vie de façon à ce
que cela leur correspondent et qu'il
puisse s'épanouir donc notamment alliés
le travail et la famille
qui sont différentes responsabilités qui
pèsent aujourd'hui sur les femmes
malheureusement nous avons davantage de
situations de monoparentalité chez les
femmes et cela génère bien sûr le fait
d'avoir
un travail et une activité
domestique un cumul des contraintes
notamment physique ce qui génère une
surexposition à terme et on le voit
notamment sur le temps alloué sur les
tâches domestiques pour 2h32 par jour
chez les femmes on retrouve deux heures
de tâches domestiques chez les hommes ce
qui augmente bien sûr la charge mentale
et réduit drastiquement le temps pour
les loisirs
on a également des différences physiques
par rapport aux hommes qui sont
physiques et physiologiques mais sur
lesquels je ne vais pas revenir puisque
nous en avons déjà parlé précédemment et
des postes qui ne sont pas
systématiquement adaptés les normes
aujourd'hui ne sont pas basées sur les
femmes sauf bien sûr la norme dont nous
avons déjà parlé qui est la x35-109 sur
le port de charge
mais les postes de manière générale
étant adaptée pour l'homme moyen les
femmes sont contraintes à faire des
efforts supplémentaires pour pouvoir
faire un travail qui peut être
identique elles ont également des
besoins différents notamment en lien
avec leur menstruations puisque
contrairement à l'imaginaire masculin
collectif il ne s'agit pas que
d'irritabilité et de douleur abdominales
il s'agit aussi de céphalées de
douleurs lombaires de vertiges etc et
qu'elles n'ont pas aujourd'hui en France
de congé menstruel il y a également des
besoins spécifiques aux grossesses au
post-partum qui dépendent bien sûr de
chaque femme de manière spécifique
on retrouve entre 2001 et 2019 une
augmentation du nombre des accidents de
travail pour les femmes et une
augmentation massive notamment dans le
secteur des activités de service avec
plus 110% des accidents de travail on a
également une augmentation sur cette
période des accidents de trajet qui ont
été multipliés par deux par rapport aux
hommes toujours sur ce type d'activité
donc les activités de service le soin on
pense aux assistantes maternelles aux
aides-soignantes
aux personnes
des services d'entretien et puis on a
des durées d'arrêt de travail qui sont
plus longues pour les femmes par rapport
aux hommes sauf dans le secteur du BTP
qui reste un secteur extrêmement exposé
aux diverses aux diverses contraintes
selon le comité régional d'orientation
des conditions de travail de Bretagne
aujourd'hui
en tout cas en 2019 on retrouvait entre
32 et 40% des femmes qui étaient
victimes de harcèlement sexuel au
travail ou d'agression sexuelle ou de
viol les 40% correspondent notamment au
cadre et les 32% sur les autres statuts
et 80% des salariés feraient face à des
attitudes sexistes
ceci étant une étude bien sûr sur une
échelle mais on pourrait bien sûr
estimer que cela est sous-évalué puisque
aujourd'hui les femmes
en France et dans le monde sont
globalement toutes victimes au moins
d'attitude sexistes aujourd'hui je pense
que personne dans cet assemblée ne
pourrait dire qu'elle n'a pas connu au
moins verbalement d'attitude sexistes
envers elle et donc pour les femmes les
risques professionnels sont différents
puisque on peut en ajouter par rapport
aux hommes
on a les risques classiques bien sûr qui
vont être des risques thermiques des
risques physiques des risques liés aux
produits utilisés donc qui engendre des
maladies on peut avoir des risques liés
au bruit etc mais également un risque de
violence et de discrimination
et c'est ici que je vais faire du lien
donc avec mon activité d'experts
endommage corporel parce qu'aujourd'hui
les femmes sont victimes de violence qui
sont conjugales ou non qui sont liés à
des agressions des viols des mutilations
et
tout cela engendre des conséquences
physiques mais aussi psychologiques qui
sont gravissimes des limitations qui
sont fonctionnelles des pertes de
mobilité des pertes de sensibilité et
donc cela va influer forcément sur le
travail puisque on peut avoir des arrêts
bien sûr et puis parfois un changement
d'orientation puisque si ces incidents
malheureux ont lieu sur le lieu de
travail en général on n'a pas envie d'y
retourner donc on va avoir des
changements dans les habitudes de vie et
même des conduites d'évitement ce qui
signifie que finalement la vie
antérieure n'est plus retrouvée
je vais faire un petit focus sur la
santé et le handicap
puisque ça va pas été fait auparavant et
en tant qu'ergothérapeute effectivement
je vais prêcher pour ma paroisse
aujourd'hui la définition la plus connue
de la santé c'est celle de l'OMS qui
définit la santé comme un état complet
de bien-être qu'il soit physique mental
social
et qui ne consiste pas en une absence de
maladie ou d'infirmité
et le handicap c'est toute limitation
d'activité ou même seulement une
restriction une restriction de
participation à la vie en société qui va
être dans un environnement donné pour
une personne et qui génère une
altération substantielle durable ou même
définitive d'une ou plusieurs fonctions
qu'elles soient physiques sensorielles
mentale cognitive ou psychique d'un
polyhandicap ou d'un trouble de santé
invalidant et je tiens à rappeler que
80% des handicaps sont invisibles donc
on peut très bien être dans une
situation de travail et que notre
employeur d'ailleurs ne soit pas au
courant que nous sommes en situation de
handicap puisque les chiffres que je
vous donnerai juste après tiennent
compte des personnes qui ont une
déclaration de reconnaissance en tant
que travailleur handicapé mais pour
avoir cette reconnaissance il faut avoir
fait des démarches et pour cela il faut
constituer un dossier auprès de la
Maison départementale des personnes
handicapées sans cela on a nos
pathologies nous handicaps et nous ne
sommes pas reconnus aujourd'hui en
France on considère qu'il y a en moyenne
2,7 millions de personnes entre 15 et 64
ans qui ont une reconnaissance
administrative en lien avec le handicap
ou une perte d'autonomie et 50%
correspond à des femmes donc ça
correspond à 1,35 millions de personnes
enfin de femmes en 2020
et sur la population globale les 2,7
millions de personnes on a deux on a
pardon
955000 personnes qui travaillent donc ça
pose quand même question pourquoi autant
de personnes en situation de handicap ne
travaillent pas alors pour les jeunes
bien sûr il y a la question de
l'insertion professionnelle mais
il n'y a pas la moitié de cette
population qui est en situation de
formation normalement
les femmes en situation de handicap sont
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus touchés par le
sous-emploi cela signifie qu'elle
travaille mais qu'elles vont travailler
à temps partiel même si elles souhaitent
et peuvent travailler davantage
elles ont également un taux d'inactivité
plus élevé que les hommes
et elles sont touchées par le chômage
davantage que le reste de la population
française donc aujourd'hui une femme qui
en plus un double handicap subit une
double discrimination celle du genre et
celle du handicap
nous avons cependant des axes de travail
que ce soit pour les entreprises ou
même de manière plus globale pour la
formation le la première chose c'est
d'évaluer donc sur le terrain il s'agit
d'évaluer les risques qu'ils soient
individuels comme collectif et d'y
inclure la dimension du genre parce que
l'évaluation si elle est trop globale au
final ne pourra pas inclure la femme et
on restera sur les mêmes problématiques
que nous avons actuellement donc il
s'agit de faire émerger aussi des
situations de discrimination qui sont
liées notamment à cette construction
sociale que nous avons avec des normes
culturelles
et puis il s'agit aussi de parler de la
variabilité interne et un train
individuel la variabilité
inter-individuelle c'est celle que nous
avons entre deux personnes et la
variabilité intrins individuelle c'est
toutes les fluxations que nous pouvons
avoir au sein de notre propre corps et
au sein d'une même journée au sein d'une
même période c'est-à-dire que je ne suis
pas dans les mêmes dispositions à cet
instant que dans quelques heures quand
je ne serai plus ici et mes capacités ne
seront pas forcément les mêmes puisque
les tâches seront différentes aussi
il faut ensuite prévenir et plus on
prévient de manière précoce plus nos
adaptations pourront être efficaces et
l'adaptation permet aussi la performance
donc cela permet aussi de lier
productivité et santé donc c'est un
double bénéfice que ce soit pour les
entreprises qui effectivement auront
moins d'arrêt de travail donc c'est dans
leur intérêt moins de maladies
professionnelles et également pour les
salariés qui souffriront moins
on doit également éduquer donc par le
biais de sensibilisation de formation de
conseils alors cela peut se faire bien
sûr en interne on entend souvent des des
formations qui se font sur quelques
heures ou quelques jours dans les
entreprises alors on entend la fameuse
formation geste et posture mais on peut
en faire sur énormément de sujets qui
vont toucher toutes les difficultés
qu'on a évoquées aujourd'hui notamment
les risques psychosociaux que l'on
évoque à mon sens beaucoup trop peu et
puis il s'agit aussi d'évoquer tous les
risques qui ont été cités aujourd'hui
dans les formations initiales et pas que
au niveau des ressources humaines mais
au niveau managérial de manière globale
au niveau de tous les métiers puisque
tous les métiers sont à risque
aujourd'hui il y a aucun métier qui n'a
pas de risque professionnel
et puis il s'agit de favoriser aussi la
mixité puisque aujourd'hui
les femmes sont sous représentées au
niveau hiérarchique et donc plus on
favorise la mixité plus on pourra aussi
favoriser cette prévention puisque les
femmes sont peut-être plus impliquées
dans dans ces sujets qui les concernent
et tout cela nécessite un accompagnement
vers des changements qui sont
organisations
techniques architecturaux et aussi de
compréhension de l'autre compréhension
de l'autre que ce soit au niveau du
genre mais aussi au niveau du handicap
puisque chaque handicap est différent et
chaque personne est différente mais au
sein d'un même groupe d'individus au
sein d'un même groupe de travailleurs
comprendre l'autre acidificité l'autre
et ses différentes permet de limiter les
discriminations et un meilleur vécu au
travail de manière très globale
alors pour cela bien sûr il y a des
professionnels qui peuvent intervenir il
y a les ergothérapeutes qui sont des
professionnels de santé diplômés d'état
qui vont intervenir auprès de tous types
de population aujourd'hui dans notre
métier
notre objectif est que la personne soit
autonome dans ses activités de vie
quotidienne donc s'il y a une difficulté
dans une activité de vie quotidienne
notamment le travail nous pouvons
intervenir par le biais d'analyse
d'activités qui feront le lien entre
l'activité et la santé et tout cela sera
remis au sein de l'environnement de
façon à recontextualiser et être le plus
proche de l'activité réalisée
il est aussi possible bien sûr de faire
des spécialisations donc que ce soit au
niveau du travail ou au niveau
judiciaire comme pour ma part mais ce
sont des formations spécifiques qui
permettent d'avoir bien sûr un oeil plus
fin sur certains domaines et l'ergonome
est un professionnel qui n'est pas
professionnel de santé mais qui est
spécialiste de l'adaptation du travail
humain à l'être humain
sont son travail va se baser sur une
recherche entre les interactions entre
le travail et ces différentes
composantes et pour cela il va falloir
mettre en oeuvre et utiliser différentes
connaissances qui sont scientifiques
pour concevoir bien sûr des outils des
postes de travail des machines qui
soient adaptées à aux personnes qui vont
les utiliser de façon à être confortable
lors du travail et effectuer un travail
sécurisé et surtout efficace donc tout
l'intérêt et que l'utilisateur soit
protégé et soit performant donc c'est
toujours un double bénéfice que ce soit
pour l'entreprise ou pour le travailleur
et dans ce contexte les professionnels
doivent aujourd'hui impérativement
articuler les facteurs biomécaniques
techniques psychosociaux mais dès
l'évaluation prendre en compte les
besoins spécifiques liés aux femmes
parce que sans cela on ne pourra pas
faire évoluer les mentalités et faire
évoluer les situations de manière
spécifique aux femmes
voilà et n'hésitez pas si vous avez des
questions
merci beaucoup mesdames pour cette
présentation chacune dans vos domaines
et qui se sont ces présentations qui se
sont complétées de manière judicieuse
donc merci d'avoir eu finalement
l'intérêt de des présentations accordées
à chacune et aux autres puis finalement
un permis de d'avoir une vision
d'ensemble très complète je vais laisser
la parole à mesdames les rapporteurs si
elles souhaitent poser des questions
intervenir donc d'abord Marie-Pierre
Richer qui souhaite vous interroger je
vous remercie
merci mesdames pour votre présentation
alors je vais terminer par vous madame
puisque vous avez parlé du handicap donc
je vais enchaîner mes questions
concernant le handicap puisque vous avez
relevé les problématiques de handicap du
au travail mais
qu'elle en est des femmes handicapées
avant même de travailler on sait
qu'elles sont elles ont plus de
problèmes de recrutement que que les
hommes
qu'elles en sont les freins et à votre à
votre avis qu'elles en sont les leviers
qui permettraient de les accompagner je
crois que la délégation avait fait un
travail sur femme et Handicap je pense
que c'est à plus sur les violences
c'était pas forcément d'accord mais je
pense que ça ça fait aussi partie de la
santé des femmes handicapées
au travail vous avez les unes et les
autres évoquées aussi les conditions de
travail des femmes dans les secteurs
d'activité mais quid dans les
entreprises en fonction du nombre de
salariés
ou alors j'ai pas bien suivi mais j'ai
pas entendu si vous aviez étudié la
différenciation entre des grandes
entreprises des TPE des PME je pense que
c'est pour moi ce serait aussi tout
aussi intéressant et puis madame chaper
vous avez parlé de Karen missing et
j'aimerais avoir votre avis parce que
j'ai lu que pourrait elle estime qu'un
des éléments central pour améliorer les
conditions de travail des femmes et la
solidarité féminine elle en illustre la
portée en décrivant la création le
développement et les apports du centre
de recherche interdisciplinaire sur le
bien-être la santé la société et
l'environnement symbiose au Québec elle
trouve que l'influence de ce centre fut
selon elle positive sur l'orientation
des politiques publiques parce qu'il
parvient à démontrer que les
travailleuses étaient mal étudiées mal
protégés mal indemnisés par les agences
gouvernementales bien sûr là on parle du
Québec mais je voudrais avoir votre avis
si un centre de cette sorte serait à
même de rendre moins invisible la
problématique de la santé des femmes des
femmes au travail merci merci beaucoup
madame la rapporteur alors Florence
chaper est directement interpellé donc
j'imagine que vous allez répondre madame
et puis les autres
intervenantes de ce matin pourront
compléter les questions des réponses aux
questions posées par Madame la
rapporteur à vous madame chacun
je vais démarrer par la dernière
question effectivement et d'ailleurs
l'anacte m'avait envoyé au symbiose il y
a 10 ans en 2012 pour prendre
connaissance des travaux menés notamment
au Québec sur la question de la santé au
travail des femmes et des hommes et à
l'époque le Québec était beaucoup plus
en avant que la France depuis nous avons
beaucoup progressé on a rattrapé quand
même beaucoup de retard alors quand
Karen Messing fait
référence à la solidarité féminine il me
semble qu'il y a deux choses qu'elle
évoque de niveau différents elle parle
d'une part des espaces de parole dans
les entreprises qu'on appelle doualaque
les espaces de discussion
qui permettent aux femmes mais aux
hommes au travail d'échanger sur leurs
problématiques de travail sur la
meilleure manière de travailler et de
fait alors ça c'est aussi une question
de culture au Québec il y a plus de
groupes non mixtes de femmes et
d'ailleurs d'hommes vous connaissez la
question des masculinités aussi qui
montent en puissance qui
réfléchissent discute par rapport à leur
travail nous en France on n'a pas cette
culture
bien que les évolutions sociétales ont
constatent des évolutions dans le sens
dans la société
de
fait de pouvoir avoir des groupes
spécifiques de femmes par exemple qui se
réunissent pour parler de leur travail
ceci dit les femmes cadres les
associations cadres dans les grandes
entreprises même si elles invitent les
hommes et puis on a des revendications
aussi qu'on observe dans la société
civile de la jeune génération
sur le fait de développer la sororité
etc ceci dit moi-même quand je suis
intervenu sur la question des violences
sexistes et sexuelles au travail je suis
intervenue dans des structures où j'ai
interviewé le comité de direction le CHS
était à l'époque et j'ai dû faire des
groupes de travail séparés femmes et
hommes pour que il et elle puisse
s'exprimer par rapport à ce sujet qui
était tabou la question des règles c'est
une question tabou les problèmes gynéco
d'endométriose etc je vois mal
effectivement aujourd'hui des groupes
mixtes en parler même si c'est bien que
nos sujets de santé au travail les
hommes effectivement puissent puissent
s'en emparer
voilà alors ça c'est la question et
c'est vrai que il reste un problème en
entreprise comment parler de ce sujet
sans comme le disait très bien Agnès à
la fin de son intervention et j'avais
apporter la mienne pour pas évoquer ta
dernière slide mais j'aurais dit
exactement la même chose à savoir il y a
tellement un risque de discrimination
positive ou négative d'ailleurs un
risque de
naturalisation et de renvoi à la
dimension biologique
naturalisante des femmes donc
stigmatisantes que c'est vrai que c'est
pas évident de parler de ce sujet en
entreprise et je dois vous dire à la
branche courrier de notre grande
entreprise que vous connaissez le fait
que les femmes factrices parlent du fait
que leur plus grand problème numéro un
c'était de pouvoir aller aux toilettes
quand elles font leur tourner et que
toutes les femmes factrices ont eu des
infections urinaires des cystites
c'était la première fois que ça
remontait au comité de direction de
cette entreprise sur la branche courrier
c'est 150000 personnes et que les
syndicats médecins du travail
ce sujet publiquement comme n’étant plus
un tabou et de fait qu'ils ont choisi
ils ont ils ont du coup dans le travail
sur les tournées identifier des lieux
des mairies des écoles où les femmes
factrices pourraient aller parce que ça
se posait surtout en milieu rural et de
fait les besoins physiologiques des
femmes par rapport aux hommes ne sont
pas exactement les mêmes donc là c'est
le fait des groupes de discussion
maintenant vous évoquez le symbiose le
symbiose c'est un département de
recherche au sein de l'UQAM l'Université
du Québec à Montréal qui a créé des
partenariats et des alliances avec les
syndicats
avec les syndicats représentant les
salariés et c'est ce partenariat qui a
été très intéressant pour faire monter
les problèmes du terrain que rencontrer
les femmes moi en France c'est vrai que
nous n'avons bien que nous travaillions
alors comme Lian enfin nous nous sommes
très partis on n'est pas bi partout dans
des très partis dans notre conseil
d'administration on a l'état les
représentations des organisations
syndicales de salariés et patronales
donc nous travaillons plutôt sous ce
mandat si je puis dire tri par trique
donc quand on va mettre en place des
actions on ne va pas travailler qu'avec
un type de syndicat plutôt plutôt que
l'autre nous avons des liens
à la fois collectifs au niveau des
instances de gouvernance mais aussi
unilatérale avec chacun des
représentants de des employeurs ou des
salariés moi ce que je recommande en
France et il me semble que c'est un
point qui a été évoqué dans une des
précédentes
audition c'est de créer un comme ça a
été fait du coup au Canada et non plus
au Québec un institut de la recherche en
santé pour les femmes et pour les hommes
qui prennent en compte ces questions de
sexe et genre aussi bien pour la santé
les enjeux de santé publique que les
enjeux de santé au travail vraiment ce
que je recommande pour arriver à booster
ce sujet lui donner des moyens etc mais
c'est vrai Catherine Vidal vous a parlé
d'une d'un gros projet qui démarrait
avec 10 millions d'euros sur ce sujet je
sais pas si on sentait publique ou santé
au travail en tout cas il faut pas
oublier la santé au travail et moi je
recommande la création effectivement
d'un institut de recherche alors
recherche action parce qu'on a bien vu
que dans nos métiers on est ancré sur
les situations de travail nos différents
métiers ne peuvent pas se faire sans
aller sur le terrain puisqu'il y a ce
tel décalage prescrit réel dont parler
l'adresse en première audition voilà
alors deuxième point sur les secteurs
d'activité c'est vrai que nous nous
intervenons dans les petites entreprises
et aussi dans des grandes je dois dire
que je n'ai pas l'adresse aurait
peut-être les éléments où il y a des je
sais pas
d'éléments la statistique à vous donner
sur les conditions de travail d'une
manière générale entre les petites
entreprises et les grandes de fait je
n'ai pas moi-même
[Musique]
disons creusé ce sujet mais il y a
sûrement des études la question première
que je me pose par rapport à ça c'est
effectivement la question des marges de
manœuvre est-ce que d'une dans une
grande entreprise
les femmes auraient plus ou moins de
marge de manœuvre que dans une petite
entreprise
je sais pas si c'est une question genre
ou pas en tout cas les grandes
entreprises ont connu un phénomène
d'intensification du important du
travail de standardisation et
d'intensification qui de mon analyse a
impacter plus négativement les femmes
que les hommes j'aurais dit spontanément
mais ça n'est pas du tout appuyé c'est
empirique sur une statistiques que
peut-être dans une petite et moyenne
entreprise d'une certaine manière les
métiers étant plus complets et moins
spécialisé moins
comment dire uni uni tâche si je puis
dire les
les femmes et les hommes d'ailleurs ont
plus de marge manœuvre etc mais ça n'est
pas du tout appuyé voilà il faudrait
immédiatement des recherches que vous
connaissez peut-être voilà je m'arrête
là
madame hoplait Cuvelier qui souhaitait
compléter les merci oui je souhaitais
compléter alors effectivement je n'ai
pas de données sur les différences qui
pourraient exister en matière de risque
professionnel pour les femmes dans les
petites entreprises et dans les grandes
entreprises je pense que
on va trouver des points discriminants
sur des et des relations qui finalement
peuvent être opposées entre les uns et
les autres on peut supposer que dans les
grandes entreprises la représentation
syndicale est plus importante que dans
un certain nombre de petites entreprises
et qu'elles pourraient faire entendre
leur voix d'une façon plus favorable
dans ces grandes entreprises dans le
même temps on constate souvent une forte
discrimination dans la répartition des
postes des tâches dans les grandes
entreprises avec des assignations qui
sont liées effectivement à une forte
standardisation des postes et donc je ne
suis pas
déjà dit que les marges de manoeuvre
soient plus importantes dans les grandes
que dans les petites et on peut on
pourrait supposer effectivement que les
femmes ont eu plus de latitude
décisionnelles et d'autonomie et les
salariés d'une façon générale dans des
petites entreprises avec des
possibilités de régulation en boucle
courte avec les hiérarchiques directes
etc
néanmoins
dans les petites entreprises les
activités ne sont pas les mêmes que dans
les grandes elles peuvent avoir aussi
une moindre information une moindre
sensibilisation et moins de moyens de
prévention que dans les grandes
entreprises donc finalement on a
beaucoup de facteurs qui peuvent être en
faveur ou en défaveur de la santé des
femmes dans les grandes et petites
structures et je n'ai malheureusement
pas de données statistiques à vous
donner sur ce point voilà je tenais
quand même à préciser aussi que
l'Institut national de recherche et de
sécurité on effectue des travaux qui
peuvent
considérer les questions de genre
puisque
en matière de toxicologie par exemple il
existe des études expérimentales qui ont
pour objectif d'évaluer les risques liés
à l'exposition à un certain nombre de
toxiques qui peuvent être toxiques pour
la reproduction notamment évidemment de
façon très différenciée pour le sexe
féminin et le sexe masculin et donc ces
recherches sont très rigoureuses et
approfondie et nous prenons en compte de
façon la plus systématique possible les
différences de sexe dans l'ensemble des
études qui sont faites lorsque cela est
possible alors je dis lorsque cela est
possible parce qu'il nous arrive aussi
de favoriser parfois des recherches qui
vont considérer le genre féminin de
façon préférentielle ou le genre
masculin de façon préférentielle en
fonction des situations et notamment en
matière épidémiologique où on n'a pas
toujours la possibilité d'avoir accès à
des personnes de sexe masculin par
exemple qui serait peu nombreuses dans
un secteur d'activité ou des personnes
de sexe féminin qui serait prennent peu
nombreuses dans un secteur d'activité et
qui nous empêche d'obtenir la puissance
statistique suffisante pour apporter des
éléments de preuve
épidémiologiques mais d'une façon
générale chaque fois que c'est possible
on prend évidemment en compte les deux
genres dans nos dans nos études
merci Docteur je crois que madame qui
était en visio Karine Briard souhaitait
intervenir je vous laisse la parole
des différences selon le la taille des
entreprises alors à ma connaissance il
n'y a pas de il n'y a pas d'étude
quantitatives sur sur les différents
expositions professionnelles alors par
contre c'est un sujet que vous
m'intéresserait de creuser puisque c'est
un des facteurs observables qu'on a dans
des données quantitatives et notamment
dans l'enquête condition de travail donc
ça fait partie des facteurs que je que
je pourrais creuser et que donc voilà ça
peut ça peut prendre plusieurs semaines
mais pour pour mener ces travaux mais
c'est tout à fait intéressant
effectivement et comme cela vient d'être
dit je pense qu'il n'y a pas de de
réponse forcément univoque sur le sur
cette question là il peut y avoir des
petites je pense que ça dépend vraiment
des secteurs d'activité des
environnements de travail des des
cultures d'entreprise et donc
je pense que c'est l'analyse peut-être
au-delà des chiffres il faut vraiment
regarder finement
les par exemple si ce sont des petits
entreprises dans un urbaine ou rural ou
des grandes entreprises dans un urbaine
ou rurales les secteurs d'activités etc
et
donc voilà et je ne reviens pas surtout
surtout les arguments qui viennent
d'être évoqués parce que je l'ai rejoins
complètement il n'y a pas d'évidence je
pense sur sur ce qu'on pourrait trouver
comme ça les deux fêtes c'est
intéressant à creuser
merci beaucoup madame pour ces
compléments de réponse je vais passer la
parole à la rapporteur Annick jacquemay
et vous interviendrez comme vous
souhaitez vous organiser mesdames pour
lui répondre merci à vous madame la
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente
cher Annick d'abord mesdames et j'ai
inclus bien sûr madame en vidéo en vidéo
je voulais vous remercier pour vos
exposés bien structurés bien détaillées
très intéressant et qui recoupe
finalement les auditions qu'on a déjà
été
amenés à entendre mais finalement c'est
bien parce que tout va dans le même sens
alors j'aurais un certain nombre de
questions à vous poser on a déjà
largement abordé la question des
entreprises avec ma collègue et puis les
réponses que vous avez fournies
[Musique]
une de mes questions aussi est-ce que
vous pensez pas que la relation qui a
entre un chef d'entreprise et ses
employés ou ses salariés et peut-être
plus proche dans les petites entreprises
que dans des grandes entreprises alors
bien sûr on a parlé des syndicats qui
ont un rôle considérable à jouer
et par rapport au poste de travail et ce
que les
postes étant souvent interchangeables
est-ce que les machines ou les postes de
travail sont adaptables d'une
comment dire entre les hommes et les
femmes au niveau des tailles au niveau
de tout ce que vous avez indiqué et
sinon est-ce qu'il est possible dans
certaines chaînes ou dans certaines
entreprises de spécifier
les postes de travail sans après rentrer
dans ce qu'on appelle les risques de
discrimination ou de renforcement de
stéréotypes de genre puisqu'on a
toujours aussi un peu cette huile
d'amoclès au dessus de la tête
je crois que c'est vous madame oublie
qui avait parlé des moindres
opportunités d'évolution professionnelle
pour les femmes que pour les hommes
est-ce que vous avez pu lier ça à une
différence de formation au cours de la
vie professionnelle est-ce que c'est lié
à ça ou est-ce que c'est lié à autre
chose et à quoi
et enfin je terminerai par vous
madame beyor Guérin au niveau des
ergothérapies et ce qu'il y a des
ergothérapeutes qui travaillent au sein
de la médecine du travail et ce que les
médecins du travail sont formés
à cette spécialisation et est-ce que les
ergonomes
travaillent avec les fabricants de
machines de conception d'outils pour
justement aussi apporter leur vision des
choses et enfin une dernière question un
peu plus générale
peut-être plus philosophique la
maternité est-ce une contrainte ou un
épanouissement parce que
non mais parce que très souvent quand ça
c'est un petit peu ce qui me frappe dans
les auditions qu'on mène c'est que la
maternité enfin moi je la ressens à vous
entendre je la ressens plus souvent
comme une contrainte et moi je trouve
que c'est un épanouissement qui au
contraire devrait aussi aider les femmes
à se réaliser
voilà je vous remercie merci Madame la
rapporteur déjà cette dernière question
je pense que individuellement chacun en
dehors des fonctions que vous pouvez
occuper vous pourriez répondre
différemment et personnellement chacun
pourrait y répondre différemment pour
avoir occupé une fonction
proche en termes d'itinérance
du métier que lequel vous faisiez
référence tout à l'heure j'étais
directrice commerciale je faisais 300 km
tous les jours il était plus compliqué
de trouver aussi des toilettes avant
d'arriver chez les clients donc
[Musique]
la grossesse avec 300 km tous les jours
aussi n'était pas du tout source
d'évanouissement pour moi-même mais je
vais vous laisser répondre
parce qu'il y avait voilà il y avait
cette contrainte et cette inquiétude
donc vous voulez compléter votre
question madame la rapporter
la maternité au sens large le fait
d'avoir des enfants de les élever de les
accompagner de les voilà pas uniquement
j'allais dire le côté technique voilà
mais voilà le côté enfant éducation
enfin très bien c'est plus dans ce sens
là alors il y avait des questions à vous
qui n'aviez pas Madame larrigue
thérapeute qui n'avait pas été
sollicitée sur le premier flot de
questions donc je vais vous laisser
démarrer oui mais vous n'aviez pas
répondu oui donc vous n'aviez pas
répondu donc je vais vous commencer par
vous madame alors je vais essayer de
reprendre toutes les questions alors
déjà
vis-à-vis des postes qui seraient
adaptables entre les hommes et les
femmes bien sûr qu'il en existe
tous ne le sont pas puisque il y a des
machines qui sont conçues de telle
manière que l'adaptation est complexe
par contre bien sûr il existe de
nombreux postes qui peuvent s'adapter
que ce soit au niveau technique ou au
niveau organisationnel
mais tout cela reste à prendre au cas
par cas bien sûr en fonction de
l'activité réalisée au sein de
l'entreprise et de comment elle est
réalisée c'est pour ça que l'évaluation
doit être faite de manière précise et
non pas adapté à chaque entreprise
puisque ça n'aurait pas de sens ce ne
serait pas ça ne serait pas adapté
justement
vie des avis des ergothérapeutes au
niveau de la médecine du travail alors
on rencontre en tout cas moi sur le
terrain je rencontre plutôt des
ergonomes
sur voilà au niveau des médecines du
travail les médecins ont l'habitude de
travailler avec des ergonomes dans tous
les cas l'ergothérapie comme l'ergonomie
sont des disciplines qui demeurent
malheureusement à mon sens trop méconnu
de du grand public si je puis dire et
d'expérience quand on rencontre surtout
en ergothérapeute c'est que quand on en
a besoin donc en général c'est pas bon
signe
il faut il faudrait davantage de de
sensibilisation là-dessus et c'est pour
ça que ça me fait vraiment très plaisir
d'être là aujourd'hui pour évoquer ces
deux métiers qui sont extrêmement
importants pour les êtres humains de
manière générale et
sinon les ergonomes sont souvent je ne
peux pas dire de manière systématique
malheureusement inclus dans la
conception de machines et d'outils bien
sûr ce n'est pas une obligation
donc on peut très bien créer un outil
quel qu'il soit et dire qu'il est
ergonomique aujourd'hui le mot
ergonomique fait vendre puisque ça veut
tout et rien dire dans la réalité un
outil qui est ergonomique c'est un outil
qui a été étudié pour le travail de d'un
être humain ou de plus voilà d'un lot
d'êtres humains
réellement voilà ce stylo que je tiens
dans les mains je suis pas convaincue
que et il ait été étudié par un ergonome
ou plusieurs ergonomes pour tel type de
préhension tel type d'écriture parce
qu'il existe plusieurs types d'écriture
etc donc oui des ergonomes et des
ergothérapeutes agissent au quotidien
mais il y a cette méconnaissance et puis
il y a aussi cette pénurie parce qu'il
faut en parler on est 15000
ergothérapeutes en France au niveau des
ergonomes je n'ai pas le chiffre exact
et puis la double casquette
ergothérapeute ergonome et aussi très
très faible à titre personnel j'en
connais seulement 6 donc c'est peu et
certains ne font que de l'ergothérapie
et d'autres ne font que de l'ergonomie
donc avoir la double casquette c'est
bien mais faut-il encore l'utiliser
voilà
enfin au niveau de la maternité
contrainte ou épanouissement alors ça
relève bien sûr d'un caractère
individuel et d'un choix en tout cas on
l'espère bien sûr pour ma part je
souhaite que tout le monde y trouve un
épanouissement mais on peut y trouver
des contraintes bien sûr physique
puisque une grossesse n'est pas
forcément aisée et puis on peut y
trouver des contraintes que ce soit par
toute l'organisation nouvelle liée
au fait d'avoir des enfants et de les
accompagner sur ce long chemin qui est
la vie et puis il faut bien sûr lier
ces contraintes ci au à nos autres
contraintes qui vont être voilà liées à
notre fameux équilibre occupationnel
donc notre travail nos loisirs et tous
nos besoins en tant que être humain
puisque on peut être mère mais on peut
aussi être femme on peut aussi être
voilà être salarié à chef d'entreprise
avoir énormément de rôles et trouver cet
équilibre c'est très compliqué et en
tout cas je souhaite à tout le monde de
le trouver pour ma part je ne l'ai pas
trouvé déjà dans mes activités
habituelles donc rajouter une contrainte
matérielle je pense que ça peut être
compliqué mais tant que c'est un choix
et un épanouissement c'est formidable
merci pour ces réponses madame docteur
voilà madame docteur
oui je voudrais apporter quelques
prépositions précisions pardon sur les
postes de travail interchangeables
adaptable faut-il les spécifier alors il
existe au plan européen une directive
machine déjà qui prévoit de prendre en
compte la diversité des personnes qui
vont être en charge d'utiliser et de
mettre en oeuvre les machines et puis
des normes qui viennent renforcer
les aspects de confort de maniabilité
d'accès à différents organes de ces
machines de façon sécuritaire et en
prenant en compte aussi la santé la
santé au travail donc il existe des
moyens en tout cas de mettre en oeuvre
toute disposition pour adapter la
machine à l'homme et non l'inverse et
quand on parle de la machine à l'homme
on parle aussi de la machine à la femme
voilà donc en termes sémantique aussi ce
sont des éléments qui seraient
intéressant de faire évoluer dans dans
les
dans l'expression courante qui peut être
utilisée sur ses aspects en matière de
de machines également et enfin
d'ergonomes pardon les
ergonomes sont de plus en plus associés
à la conception des machines il y a
beaucoup d'interactions et de
collaboration qui se joue entre
développeurs de toutes sortes
d'équipements de travail et puis équipe
d'ergonomes qui viennent compléter et
travailler dès le stade de la conception
sur les projets de réalisation c'est
aussi le cas dans les services de santé
au travail vous posiez la question les
services de prévention et de santé au
travail sont constitués d'équipes
pluridisciplinaire
dans lesquels les ergonomes ont toutes
leurs places et ils sont maintenant très
répandus en termes de d'emploi on en
trouve beaucoup aussi dans les services
de prévention et de santé au travail sur
le plan d'ergothérapie c'est un peu
différent puisque on est dans des
situations souvent de prévention de la
désinsertion professionnelle de retour
au travail et donc ce sont plutôt les
services de prévention et de santé au
travail qui vont travailler en
collaboration avec des ergonomes des
ergothérapeutes pardon qui sont plutôt
institutionnalisés qui peuvent se
trouver dans des instituts de
réadaptation fonctionnelles qui vont
pouvoir accompagner les patients futurs
repreneurs de d'emploi et de travail
dans
l'intégration en entreprise il y a un
certain nombre d'initiatives qui sont
réalisés c'est d'autant plus important
que comme vous le savez la réforme de la
santé au travail a remis aussi au
premier plan cette question de la
prévention de la désinsertion
professionnelle avec les cellules dédiée
dans les services de prévention et de
santé au travail et puis alors sur le
dernier point sur la maternité la
maternité doit être épanouissante elle
est à titre personnel pour pour toutes
les femmes je pense mais la maternité
n'est pas qu'une affaire de femme c'est
une affaire de parentalité d'abord et il
me semble que voilà les femmes doivent
pouvoir s'effen s'épanouir dans la
maternité parce que aussi leur conjoint
les papas
ont une part à jouer tout à fait
importante et égalitaire dans la prise
en charge de l'éducation et de
l'accompagnement des enfants jusqu'à
l'âge adulte et je pense que un juste
équilibre trouvé en termes de
parentalité vis-à-vis des carrières et
des parcours professionnels des hommes
et des femmes doivent permettre
d'équilibrer aussi les charges et de
proposer et de permettre des évolutions
de carrière qui soit équitables pour des
femmes comme pour les hommes quel que
soit la situation familiale de l'un et
de l'autre voilà donc c'est aussi
l'affaire de l'entreprise
parce que on sait bien sûr que les
femmes ont souvent beaucoup
d'appréhensions à annoncé une grossesse
dans leur milieu de travail de par les
conséquences que qu'elles craignent en
termes d'évolution de carrière en termes
d'accès à la formation en termes
d'avancement
et de parfois
report de charge sur certaines sur
certains aspects sur leurs collègues
parce que ça arrive aussi une infirmière
qui est enceinte un peu avoir des
problèmes de limitation de port de
charge par exemple ou d'accompagnement
de patients et la question des effectifs
à se poser à un moment donné peut-on la
remplacer peut-on compenser le temps ou
le travail qu'elle ne peut plus faire
c'est souvent une charge qui est
répartie sur d'autres personnes c'est
compliqué à vivre pour elle c'est
compliqué à vivre pour l'équipe donc
voilà il y a tout un ensemble de
facteurs à mettre en oeuvre et en et en
branle pour pouvoir faire face à ces
situations qui peuvent être angoissantes
pour pour les femmes et
malheureusement venir freiner leur
épanouissement dans la maternité à tous
les à toutes les étapes
merci beaucoup madame donc Madame
Chabert souhaitait compléter oui par
rapport à vos questions alors la loi de
l'application des lois et est-ce qu'il y
a des manques
la loi 2014 c'était deux choses sur ce
sujet donc la production d'indicateurs
sexuels en santé sécurité de au travail
mais comme je vous l'ai dit le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui avec la bdese les
entreprises
choisissent enfin les partenaires
sociaux choisissent les indicateurs
dont ils s'empare pour faire leur
diagnostic leur négociation etc donc il
n'y a plus d'obligations entre
guillemets de produire des données
sexuelles dans le domaine conditions de
travail santé sécurité donc c'est quand
même embêtant donc moi je recommanderais
quand même au niveau de la BDS
effectivement une le fait de gens sexué
systématiquement les données par exemple
de la BDS je sais pas si c'est un
complément de loi ou page je n'en sais
rien mais en tout cas d'aller dans ce
sens deuxième élément de la loi ce que
Agnès a présenté au niveau de ce cet
évaluation des risques professionnels
qui doit prendre en compte l'impact
différentiel exposition en fonction du
sexe aujourd'hui
donc c'est sa date c'est une loi qui
date de 2014 mais les entreprises ne
sont pas du tout en paraît aujourd'hui
dans le Plan Santé au Travail numéro 4
et dans huit plan régionaux ont décidé
de travailler à outiller ce sujet avec
les partenaires en région et aux
nationales
ça n'est pas si simple parce qu'il
s'agit pas non plus de faire une usine à
gaz c'est effectivement quels sont les
points de repère méthodologiques pour ne
pas louper entre guillemets des risques
auxquels sont exposés les femmes dans
leurs emplois et ne pas se concentrer
sur les risques les dangers les plus
visibles auxquelles sont exposés les
hommes et ne pas oublier certaines
situations comme la situation de
grossesse le risque
de violences sexistes et sexuelles donc
je dirais quand même autant le premier
point on peut rajouter le fait que la
bdese doit être systématiquement sexuée
à mon sens par contre la deuxième il
faut avant tout mettre en oeuvre et
impliquer dedans l'inspection du travail
et donner les moyens pour que des
organismes comme les nôtres puissent
aussi et les services de prévention
santé au travail faut-il les former les
sensibiliser les outils c'est en cours
de construction je dirais que dans cinq
ans en gros on y verra plus clair et on
aura eu déjà des expérimentations en
entreprise aujourd'hui nous au niveau de
notre réseau un acte qui s'appelle plus
un réseau parce qu'on est un plus grand
établissement public la nacte a
expérimenté
le fait de de sexuer ce document unique
dans deux entreprises voilà
et nous travaillons à cette méthodologie
sur la loi de modernisation du système
de santé de 2016 elle obligé à deux
choses la Caisse nationale d'assurance
maladie a produire des données sexuées
en santé au travail dont les accidents
de travail ça n'est pas la nacte de
produire ces données nous ne sommes pas
un organisme de publication de données
moi j'ai regardé le dernier bilan de
la Amélie enfin de l'Assurance Maladie
de 2021 effectivement il y a deux choses
qui sont sexuées le compte
personnel de prévention dont les trois
quarts concernent des hommes et il y a
les accidents de travail à bicyclette ou
en trottinette le reste les accidents de
travail les maladies professionnelles
les accidents tragiques qui sont plus
nombreux que les pour les femmes que
pour les hommes etc rien est sexué
[Musique]
c'est aussi le rôle du plan santé au
travail et nous au niveau national on a
une mission spécifique donc on
travaillera sans doute avec des
organismes comme présence etc pour
pouvoir
sexuer les données produites par les
médecins là aussi il y a aussi une
question de logiciel d'informatique qui
qui n'a pas inclus cette donnée selon le
sexe sur le code du travail
le code du travail moi je dirais
qu'il faut beaucoup plus insister non
pas sur des particularismes mais sur des
mesures qui permettent de construire des
organisations de travail des dispositifs
de prévention qui prennent en compte
toutes et tous comme là aussi souligner
l'INRS
mais peut-être que sur certains aspects
je pense aux questions de maintien en
activité des personnes qui ont des
maladies chroniques évolutives qui
concerne plus les femmes le cancer etc
il faut peut-être faire évoluer notre
régime d'arrêt maladie
de mi-temps thérapeutique pour qu'il
s'adapte mieux assez assez situation et
qui permettent à la fois de travailler
et d'être malade enfin et de se soigner
voilà sur
les vos autres questions je dirais quand
même sur l'adaptation des postes et des
machines oui théoriquement l'ergonomie
doit prendre en compte la variabilité un
terrain individuelle on l'a vu dans
notre grande entreprise de distribution
du courrier il y avait 15-20 ergonomes
et comme la beaucoup d'ergonomes ne
prenait pas en compte la variation liée
au sexe et au genre ça n'est que très
récemment qu'il y a donc ce groupe de
chercheurs genre activité santé qui
prend qui
s'est réuni pour travailler sur ce sujet
ça n'est que très récemment qui a un
symposium genre travaille
ergonomie au congrès de la self chaque
année récemment c'est à dire depuis 4 5
6 ans donc il y a quand même un travail
de sensibilisation à faire vis-à-vis des
ergonomes ainsi que des médecins
effectivement du travail et puisque je
voudrais rajouter sur l'adaptation des
matériels et des machines et des gants
etc ça n'est ça n'est pas qu'une
question effectivement enfin moi je me
demande quand même s'il faut pas faire
évoluer la norme et intégrer une
obligation de prendre en compte la
différence en fonction du sexe dans les
EPI les machines
etc mais aussi il faut faire attention
au fait qu'il y a beaucoup de questions
organisationnelles qui discriminent les
femmes ou les hommes quand on voit des
règles comme la règle de l'ancienneté ou
la mise en place du télétravail etc etc
sur le dernier point moi je dirais que
les femmes alors c'est peut-être plus un
point de vue personnel je me je
m'exprime pas avec le point de vue de
l'agence mais
les femmes ont une chance c'est qu'elles
s'investissent dans plusieurs facteurs
de vie or beaucoup d'hommes sont
malheureux aujourd'hui de n'être que
monotache je dirais leur travail c'est
l'ancien modèle donc c'est quand même
une chance il faut parler maternité
paternité effectivement de manière
équilibrée et c'est vrai que moi ce que
je pressens en réfléchissant sur les
questions d'impact aussi de la
transition écologique sur nos systèmes
de vie de travail
nos réflexions sur la soutenabilité des
systèmes de travail c'est finalement
réfléchir comment notre futur travail
pour à la fois tenir compte des limites
humaines dont celle des hommes et des
femmes délimiter écologiques je vois
qu'on va vers
une plus grande reconnaissance
du travail domestique ou de ce que
Geneviève Pruvot le
la sociologue appelle le travail de
subsistance dans les prospectives on
voit que les gens feront plus de travail
pour produire leur légumes pour produire
peut-être leur énergie avec les panneaux
solaires pour éduquer pour se soigner en
préventif et que donc et en même temps
on voit une désaffection du travail et
des jeunes générations par rapport aux
entreprises telles qu'elles sont pensées
aujourd'hui qui qui en partie peuvent
détruire les ressources de la planète
etc donc je pense qu'on va plutôt dans
le sens
d'une meilleure prise en compte à mon
sens des questions de maternité
paternité comme des questions
écologiques comme des questions voilà un
rééquilibrage plutôt global sous la
contrainte vraisemblablement
merci beaucoup pour ces réponses
complètes il y avait juste si le madame
l'a rapporteur si vous voulez intervenir
juste rapidement puisque après on a un
autre rendez-vous et en définitive ce
sera pas une question puisque vous avez
répondu moi je revenais mais peut-être
que ça pourra faire l'objet d'une
réponse écrite à la commission c'est
concernant ma question sur les femmes
handicapées ce que j'ai la question que
j'ai posée au départ se concernant les
femmes handicapées et les frais et les
leviers mais ça pourra peut-être faire
l'objet d'une réponse par écrit puisque
ça se termine et mon intervention elle
m'a dernière intervention c'était une
question mais vous y avez répondu à
savoir qu'en définitive nous travaillons
sur la santé des femmes au travail et ça
peut ouvrir des perspectives sur la
santé sur la des hommes au travail il
faut dire les deux merci beaucoup madame
la rapporteur je vais laisser quelques
minutes seulement s'il vous plaît si
vous pouvez être concise madame Briard
puisque moi j'ai un rendez-vous avec sur
un sujet qui concerne les femmes aussi
c'est la place des femmes dans la haute
fonction publique et je voilà mon
rendez-vous trouve approche et je
voudrais quand même honorer tous mes
rendez-vous du matin donc si vous pouvez
être concise tout à fait juste sur deux
points qui ont été posés par Madame
Jacquemet sur la maternité il y a un
certain nombre de travaux sur les sur la
théorie de la conservation des
ressources et sur l'enrichissement
travail famille famille travail donc là
les travaux scientifiques de
psychologues du travail en gestion des
ressources humaines qui documentent
vraiment ces questions là donc voilà et
sur le deuxième point sur les moindres
perspectives professionnelles des femmes
sur les évolutions de parcours là il
faut bien voir que tous les métiers
n'entre pas les mêmes perspectives
d'évolution et que un certain nombre de
travaux de sociologues d'économistes
d'historienne mettre en évidence le fait
qu'il y a moins de
mobilité professionnelle et de
perspective de progression
professionnelle dans des métiers très
féminisés ce qui renvoie à la
codification des postes à la
reconnaissance des compétences dans les
travaux dans les métiers féminisés donc
voilà je sur ces questions-là je
pourrais éventuellement revenir si vous
le souhaitez voilà le documenter ces
aspects là bien écoutez vraiment merci
pour vous mesdames qui avaient répondu
de manière efficace et complète à nos
questions et bien entendu madame Briard
si vous souhaitez nous envoyer des
éléments complémentaires mesdames
n'hésitez pas pour alimenter notre
réflexion et notre travail et donc vous
envoyez vous revenez vers la délégation
et on prendra connaissance de ces
éléments et de ses études avec beaucoup
d'attention je vous remercie sincèrement
toutes les quatre pour avoir participé
et vous monsieur pour avoir participé à
cette à cette table ronde ce matin je
remercie aussi évidemment la délégation
qui organise ces tables rondes et
mesdames les rapporteurs qui étaient
présentes et qui devront rejoindre leur
département comme elles pourront
aujourd'hui je l'espère merci belle
journée à tous et on regardera les
éléments que vous pourrez apporter en
supplément merci à vous